we got one heck of a story for y'all
tonight and i can't say that i'm
surprised it's on a friday a
pennsylvania statewide court has ruled
the universal mail-in voting law that
was pushed forward in 2019 is
unconstitutional
exactly as several republicans had
claimed and they filed the lawsuit now
the left is saying it's it's a
party-line vote i mean it was five
judges it was three republicans two
democrats of course it was the
republicans who said that it was
unconstitutional this is a complicated
story democrats or republicans made a
deal a deal that republicans could not
actually follow through on because the
state constitution bars universal
mail-in voting
we know this because both the democrats
and republicans are now actively trying
to amend the constitution even though
they already passed an unconstitutional
law
this country is in some deep-ish if you
know what i mean this story is
absolutely off the wall insane
so i don't i don't think this means
anything to be honest for 2020 other
than it'll make it it'll piss off trump
supporters but as for
moving forward the midterms and
potentially 2024 this could have a very
serious impact because
well we know the law is unconstitutional
the democrats and the republicans are
trying to amend the constitution to make
it that to make it legal
but they're doing it anyway so if we
have an election in november if we have
an election in 2024 after this ruling
it's going to be bonkers it's just going
to be absolute chaos but we'll talk
about that
we've also got some other crazy stories
we've got uh barry manilow apparently
there was a big rumor that he was
pulling his music off spotify over the
joe rogan thing and it was a lie
surprise surprise they're lying about
everything we got a big story apparently
black lives matter the official
organization is in shambles no one knows
where the money is going and some people
are outright saying it's basically just
a scam because the address isn't even a
real address but we'll get into all of
that joining us today is tom garrett
how's it going man hey man how are you
do you want to introduce yourself
yeah
uh yeah
no no you don't have to are you
shameless
there's no i'm just a guy who grew up in
rural virginia who's had a neat life and
got to do some cool stuff he's trying to
change the world so boom right um but
you've done so what's that what's that
cool stuff you've seen so i served in
the military uh and then got out went to
law school after i was in the military
um and uh then then served 10 years as a
prosecutor served in the virginia senate
served a term in congress but um really
got a passion for uh human rights right
that we live in a world where if you're
listening to this podcast odds are
you're very fortunate the odds of being
born in this country are 1 in 26.
um but while we speak there are people
who are being raped and murdered and
tortured and displaced
because of who they love because of how
they worship because they choose not to
worship etc etc and you know you go see
this stuff firsthand and then i sort of
was like what can i do about it and
um so that's that's that's why we're
here it's interesting you say that
because i think you know you were
mentioning just before the show that
identity politics is is really really
dangerous for us the wokeness right
well i mean
so
if you if you dissect everything into
my hair color is this or my skin color
is that then you've lost the real
essence of what's important right and
that's humanity itself
and
you know politicians and evil entities
have used uh character traits to divide
people for time and memoriam and why do
we continue to fall for that when we
have more information than any
generation in history at our fingertips
but but we do and that's identity
politics and it causes violence and
bloodshed and suffering and and uh
i'm over it one of the things that we're
going to get into on the show today is
that you're working on a documentary
series and you're on the ground in syria
i believe in syria right and
and you're having trouble getting
networks to pick it up because you're
not too kind to china
so yeah i've been
it's fun with my passport i've been uh
spent the night in three of the seven
official state sponsors of terrorism
syria iraq sudan
um and uh sort of trying to shine a
light on man's humanity fellow man at
exilesseries.com first of many egregious
plugs
um and so we go to the networks
and we show them this trailer which is
like really good like i'm the weak link
the presenters the weak link and then we
love it it's great can you do this
series without talking bad about china
and i'm like we could do a beatles dock
without talking about jon it would suck
and that's crazy but look
let's get into that because that's
that's
you were saying like well i don't want
to spoil i want to spoil it but these
networks are refusing to do it and
there's other issues too so we'll
definitely get into that we got sheamus
sitting over here good to be here thank
you for having me i am a political
cartoonist and animator and political
commentator i have a youtube channel
called freedom tunes where we make
cartoons about politics and culture so
go over there and check it out
all right ian crossland up in here uh hi
everyone ian crossland.net check me out
and i want to tell everybody that
freedom tunes is spelled
t-o-o-n-s-t-u-n-e-s because people tend
to search that as well i am sorry
patchell it's in the corner pushing
buttons gonna be a great talk well i'm
going to make freedom tunes you and es
and it's going to be a band perfect
that's perfect
we've actually done that tim i'm sorry
to tell you our music yeah wow
well anyway before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com become
a member and help support all of the
journalism that we do here your
membership helps support all of our
journalists it helps make this show
possible and you will get access to our
massive library of tim cast irl podcast
members-only segments we have a ton of
really amazing people who've been on the
show in the past so you can go there you
can search all of these crazy names and
listen to these uncensored members only
shows and again help support all of our
work but don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and the
most important thing the best thing you
can do for us is just copy that url
laptop paste it wherever you can on
whatever social network that is
grassroots marketing it's the most
powerful way to get the word out it
really really does help so we greatly
appreciate it but now let's get into
that first story man
from timcast.com pennsylvania court
strikes down mail-in voting law a u.s
district court in pennsylvania has has
ended an extension to mail-in voting
provisions which drew criticism during
the 2020 elections
let me try and give you the the quick
version of this because boy is it a
doozy in 2019 republicans want to get
rid of something
called like single single what's the i
can't even think of the phrase
i'll put it this way republicans didn't
like the fact that in pennsylvania you
could go and press one button and vote
for all democrats so they said the
democrats get rid of that they said okay
we'll get rid of that if you give us
universal mail in voting the republicans
said we can't it violates the
constitution and they said well we'll do
it anyway we'll amend the constitution
give us universal mail in voting the
republicans said we agree
99 percent in the house 98 in this in
the pennsylvania senate of of all of the
of the members agreed on this and passed
a law in violation of the state
constitution now
in comes the primary elections incomes
congress and the presidential elections
and some republicans take notice hey
wait a minute how did they pass
universal mail-in voting when it's
actually in violation of the state's
constitution state constitution outright
says absentee voting is for these
specific reasons but what the what
republicans and democrats had worked a
deal on was universal mail-in voting so
they went to sue and the judge said you
guys wait until after the primary and
after your guy lost to try and challenge
this law you could have you could have
challenged this beforehand and there's
an interesting point to be made there
but i don't think it matters i think the
problem is the democrats got swindled
the republicans agreed to a deal they
never had the right to
promise the democrats in the first place
so now here we are it is a year and a
half or so a year and a few months later
and now a state court has said yes the
constitution outright says here are the
specific reasons for absentee ballots
you cannot pass this law here's the
kicker
democrats republicans alike have agreed
on a a bill to amend the constitution to
make universal mail-in voting
constitutional it would require two
back-to-back sessions where they approve
this that's not possible to do in one
legislative session so what they decided
i guess was we'll approve the the
amendment which won't go into effect
until a second legislative hearing and a
referendum from the public
and then we'll just pass universal mail
in voting anyway
surprisingly i believe it was 11 of the
republicans who actually voted on that
law to for universal mail and voting
were involved in the lawsuit saying it
was unconstitutional so i gotta say the
republicans are kind of dicks in this
moment but i don't think that matters we
can smack talk to republicans all day
and night the law is unconstitutional
now here's where it gets crazy the
supreme court of pennsylvania is i
believe five five judges three democrats
two republicans and so it is widely
believed that the democratic supreme
court in pennsylvania is going to just
say nope it's constitutional regardless
of what the constitution says and if
they do
you're going to have a law on the books
as you do now which says you don't need
an excuse for mail-in voting and a
constitution that says you can only have
mail-in voting for these reasons ladies
and gentlemen this country's imploding
anyway guys how are you doing
so what's that like 8th grade civics
right the rule of the courts are to
interpret the laws not to make them yeah
and and it is the judicial activism is
the end of checks and balances
so yeah it's a friday hey man i'd rather
yeah like what did i say before we went
on their worst country in the world
except for all the others yeah
what do you do if the judicial system
has become political
except that you are being ruled by
judges well i mean there's got to be
some sort of constitutional recourse to
pull them out of office i would well
actually only if the legislative branch
asserts itself which it hasn't been
willing to do for the last hundred years
anyway right i mean we
we promulgate 28 pages of regulation for
every one page of laws we pass but they
can take your liberty or your property
for violation of a regulation therefore
it is tantamount to a law that means
that they've abdicated their
responsibility to legislate right and
why because it's more important to get
reelected
than it is to to do it's the the axiom
is there's two types of people in
politics so you want to be somebody and
those who want to do something and
tragically the be somebody's outnumbered
that do some things like ten to one yep
and tragically pardon me as a liberty
guy the best bulk of the do somethings
aren't on the right
i think it's true i think the simple way
to put it is the system is falling apart
it's quite simple if a judge
on party lines can say
we don't care whether this is
constitutional or not you can't you
can't do this this late right so
initially they told the republicans who
filed the lawsuit over it well it's too
bad you guys did it they were treating
the individuals in the lawsuit as a
party and not as individuals that's the
first problem the judge should not say
your guy lost and now you're suing it's
like my response would be like my guy
look that's somebody else has nothing to
do with my election
in fact one of the guys suing i think
actually won his election
so the judge first comes out the gate
the judges in general are just like
we're partisans and we know it
now it goes to the next state court and
on the merits they say yo the
constitution of pennsylvania there's a
section on absentee voting it says here
are the specific reasons you can have an
absentee vote it's like you're out of
town on business you're in the military
you're you're medically indisposed or
whatever but no excuse universal mail in
voting not allowed
so the court says okay you can't do it
now the democrats are coming out saying
we don't care we're going to do it
anyway this is going to go to the state
supreme court
and if they on party lines
uphold the law and say the laws allowed
regardless of the constitution you have
a court saying the constitution doesn't
matter at all we're going to do whatever
we want on party lines they've already
used a party-line vote in the first
place republicans are the ones who made
a bad deal don't you know they swindled
the democrats in the first place but
this means that a judge can it can enact
a law which favors democrats which will
then result in your legislators who pass
the laws being basically put in place by
broken laws the system is a hodgepodge
of duct tape and bubble gum jammed
together to hold stuff together and
we're all looking at it and i gotta be
honest it doesn't make sense
if this is if this if this moves forward
with democrats in the supreme court
being like it's a state supreme court
not the federal saying no we're going to
let this law stand i'm just like yo you
guys don't have representative
government anymore you have appointed
judges who who uphold unconstitutional
rules to allow their buddies to get
reelected no one's no one's voting for
like what's the point at that point
well i guess a point could be that you
might have a bout of corruption and then
after that it gets back to normal and
they're no longer corrupt so just
because uh one time there's a bunch of
corruption doesn't mean that it's ruined
forever keep that in mind um
i don't know how power never voluntarily
relinquishes itself it doesn't power
does not relinquish itself i think in
like these judges are they're human so
like they're morally shattered if you
get d if you get demoralized shattered
mentally shattered judges like you're
gonna see all sorts of weird behavior
the problem is
the judges and the legislators are
viewing every single person as a member
of a tribe big problem the judge
initially outright when the lawsuit
happened should have said
is it constitutional or not instead they
said who is the person who's filing the
suit ah a republican well you're you're
you're only trying to get points for the
republicans and i'm not so i say no to
you okay well that that's not law that's
just tribalism look man i've been
telling people
we are in some kind of civil war when a
judge issues a ruling and explicitly
states your guy already lost so you're
doing this for that reason it's like
that judge is not ruling on the merits
he's ruling on the tribe he's telling
one tribe you are not allowed
okay so what happens next
i mean now you have the democrats saying
this court is republican so they're
saying the exact same thing republicans
are right our tribe wins the next
court's going to be democrat democrat
wins there is no no judicial system at
that point
so welcome to america 2022 how you guys
doing well as far as i'm concerned this
is just more undermining of more
institutions and
from what i saw in 2020 there is no low
that we can possibly reach that will not
turn something partisan like the
judicial system is not intended to be
partisan in any way but they're turning
it into that which is going to be a huge
problem down the road and maybe they
don't see that as being the case because
they're very short-sighted but if you
can use it against the other party they
can obviously use it against you and yet
if there is an institution a
foundational institution that
has demonstrated that it seems to work
still
it's the judiciary usually right we got
the written house verdict followed by
the aubrey verdict right right and and i
was just watching both of them going
okay they murdered that dude and this
kid like watched the video like
i was impressed with his fire discipline
candidly well what dude got murdered
you're gonna trick you're i'm gonna get
triggered oh you're gonna trigger your
time you're gonna trigger me the guy
jogging in georgia wasn't jogging might
not should have been kicking through the
houses but yeah he was a burglary
suspect
you shot him the prosecutor called him a
burglary suspect the only reason the the
mcmichaels got convicted was because the
judge gave the instruction to the jury
that
unless they had witnessed the potential
crime taking place they had no right to
try and confront him and deadly forces
now they are never authorized for the
protection of property except ahmed
arbory grabbed the shotgun from the
mcmichael and fought him for it which is
dual possession which resulted in him
getting shot which is a good argument
and then they put the guy who filmed it
in prison for life
now from from that point you need to
start the whole ahmed arby question is
why is the guy who filmed it going to
prison for life you start to unravel the
thread from there and you realize the
whole thing is a travesty of justice
wow
dude i'm so excited to be on this
podcast
i think it's gonna get like smoked in
the first 15 minutes
well it's something i'm i'm not saying
that but you get my point
at least as the facts were distilled
from me i thought that the system that
the the judiciary had gotten it right
what their job is is to is to call balls
and strikes
and and that kind of is
politically dangerous uh because of the
tribalism that you make reference to but
kind of the way i try to do it like
you know when my guy was in the white
house and i was in congress
i had a duty to say when i thought my
guy was wrong hmm well so this the armed
armory thing is actually a really great
point to what we're talking about here
and it's why i think in many ways the
republicans are losing and probably will
lose but i do think there's a great uh
potential for national populist
republican types people who are who
believe in america
not you know we have a big problem with
corporatists crony conservatives who are
just you know rhinos i guess they call
republicans in name only the issue is
when it comes to a story like ahmed
arbory
fox news is more than happy to come out
and just praise the ruling without
looking at the facts because they want
to earn some points for them from the
mainstream media it is said that there
are many republicans who care more about
the opinion of the new york times than
their own constituents
that is why i think the republican
establishment is being gutted and ripped
apart
uh the amendment case being another
example of this where many republicans
came out were like see this was a good
ruling and then we actually had a
self-defense expert andrew branca as
well as some other lawyers come on and
break down the case and we were like oh
wow that absolutely is not true but why
were so many conservatives willing to
come out and and defend that ruling well
i think it's because
people on the right are many of them
they they care more about the opinion
not just the republicans but individuals
care more about the opinion of the new
york times than their own constituents
so you'll end up very often with
republicans being you know demure and
backing down where democrats go for the
for the ultimate sure right what happens
is republicans take control and hold the
line and democrats take control and push
the football
absolutely you get you know and you know
it's hard to lose it's hard to lose
ground on the offensive
i want to give a good example to people
because one of the narratives from the
left and democrats is that republicans
don't play but play by the rules that
republicans are steamrolling getting
whatever they want and democrats won't
fight back
democrats repeatedly call for gun
control republicans repeatedly call for
not gun control
we continually get gun control laws
where are the republicans to call for
repealing gun control you see right
democrats say we want to ban these
particular weapons the left then says no
one is coming for your guns waco
disproves that then you get republicans
saying we've already banned a bunch of
guns we'll stop here no no republicans
how about you act like lauren bobert or
marjory taylor green and repeal the nfa
abolish the atf and start passing laws
to repeal unconstitutional gun bans yeah
absolutely the contrast is astounding
because you're absolutely correct that
there are a lot of republicans who care
more about what the new york times says
than their constituents it's also the
case that there are many republicans in
general among the constituency who care
about what the new york times says more
than any democrat cares about what fox
news says the left doesn't consume media
that's generally catered towards
right-wing markets and shape their
thinking based on that or determine
which opinions they're going to be
comfortable voicing in the workplace
based on that
yeah you know i'm i'm still fairly
optimistic though because the uniparty
establishment is struggling
you know it's it's
well said right i mean so we've had one
president who was elected without a
party affiliation and we were talking i
think off air again
i i i loathe political parties yeah and
and and there are lots of people in
washington who i won't name because i'd
like to make a living um who are in the
party they're in because they analyzed
the district or the state where they
were running and and said this is the
party i need to be in right there
they're they're amorphous
uh and that's exactly who will destroy
this great thing that's been bequeathed
to us that this this this republic
so
you should if you won't divert from your
party
then you shouldn't be elected period
right number one and number two if
you'll ever take a vote to get reelected
then you should never be elected to
begin with it's that was this was this
got me in so much trouble in washington
i carried the obamacare repeal
and i was told by leadership dude you
can't carry the obamacare appeal and i'm
like you mean the one that you and
everybody else with an arbiter named
voted for last year and like yeah
because now we have both houses in the
white house
so you oh wait hang on i can't carry it
because it might pass yes and i'm like
oh yeah so this was kabuki theater to
placate a bass that they'd think that
they look down their noses out and think
he's ignorant um and then when we have
the ability to get it done then they go
you can't do that why not because what
what what then
and
the first day i was in the state senate
i cannot remember the issue but the the
the majority leader is like well we what
do we do about this and i said
new guy what about this and he goes
they'll they'll they'll say we're racist
and i said dude they're already right
what if we just do the right thing and
trust that african americans and
caucasian americans and all americans go
son of a god those guys did the right
thing
you know so like and that was another
thing we talked about off air like i
cared too much what people said but it
never was able to to to change sort of
what i was gonna do
um you guys are amazing because i've
read the crap they say about you
and and that's that's what happens to
republicans they get called into sort of
submitting well that's that's the point
i was making about the armoured armory
thing you know that you you could say on
the question of the law as as as the
judge ordered the jury they made the
right call but when you actually break
it down and look at the full story i
mean a gun had been stolen from a car a
gun had been stolen and uh there had
been a string of robberies the neighbors
were scared they were setting up cameras
everywhere the police went door to door
and said here's a picture of the guy
we're looking for someone sees the guy
running down the street surveillance
footage foot caught him in the building
the night before and the guys are like
let's stop him and get the cops so they
call the police but the police said
don't pursue they pursue it anyway dude
they flanked him to the front he runs
after him guy drives behind him filming
he he goes to the to the right around
the truck and then grabs one of the
mcmichael's shotgun they fight for it it
goes off he gets shot in the chest he
dies
now we're in in the case where the
narrative on the left was he was just
jogging you're just jogging what like 20
miles from his own house no no but why
did mcmichaels grab a gun and go after
him well because a gun had been stolen
and i'm not saying it was the right
thing but the judge basically said
if the law is to be read that you need
to witness the crime then they stopped
him illegally which is a felony and
because he died in the struggle it's
felony murder
yeah right the felony would be um uh
i think false imprisonment
kidnapping essentially yeah but the but
the law actually states you have a right
to stop someone if you suspect a felony
well here's a story to me right as a guy
who just got sort of schooled on this
the story to me is that i consider
myself to be marginally well-read and
half the stuff you said i'd never heard
that's wild
right i mean you see where i'm going
with this tim right like shout out to
legal insurrection dot com and law of
self defense and your breakup because
they actually trained trained on
self-defense on self-defense law in the
and and circumstances under we had a
long phone call in the snow on the way
up here about
this dude's like well if i shoot the
intruder with number four versus double
up buck and i'm like it doesn't matter
you sure it's deadly force anyway so we
don't overthink this we've talked a lot
a lot about that too but but you know
back to the main point it's that these
republicans the ones you mentioned that
they're like oh we can't actually repeal
obamacare because then we have no i
guess you know what no political animals
they took like three or four votes where
they all voted for it and then i had to
do a discharge petition which is where
you try to get a number of members to
sign a bill to get a vote on it on the
floor because the speaker won't bring it
who was a republican wow and i got like
26 signatures on the discharge position
people wouldn't even sign the document
to let it come to a vote
because they didn't want to be held
accountable and i'm like like it took me
less than 24 hours to go this place is
broken beyond my ability to repair it
this is why i went back to the armed
armory thing the fox news personalities
and the conservatives who are unwilling
to actually look into it and call it out
because they're scared of being called
racist or whatever yo i got called
racist when i said all that stuff and
they i'm like i literally don't care
that you call me that that word has zero
meaning to me or anybody else at this
point
it's well it it's like it's what what's
worse that you could call somebody in
2022.
i don't think there's i don't think you
call him anything to be honest but
again that's the point though and so
but
so i did a radio show for a while and
the last few segments were more or less
on philosophy and the rhetorical
question was if you could choose between
freedom and truth which would you choose
and my answer is you always choose truth
because truth will beget freedom exactly
and the truth is freaking dead
yeah they get to define truth right and
that's that's that's exile series.com
again i'm shameless plug is like the
people know what's going on people
demand it's done differently you you
mentioned um republicans saying we can't
pass that
they would call us racist
that was a different that was something
the state senate i can't even remember
what it was oh okay but i remember the
majority leader going there well they're
gonna say such and such and i'm like
they're already saying it yeah they're
saying worse than that dude but that
come on that that you know
i hear you're saying that that was
during the state senate but i have to
imagine that's that's that's everywhere
for republicans so when some series is
of african american woman elected
lieutenant governor of virginia and
there was a story in a legitimate
media outlet about how that proved how
racist republicans were like the mental
gymnastics you have to do to get to that
point right i feel that it requires like
a level of uh spiritual toughness to
navigate criticism like this in the
internet age the comments and the the
news articles so like these people can't
do it obviously they tried and failed
they're they're older they're not used
to the internet um like some young
people are
i thought i see them as a vulnerability
having individuals there that can get
their morale shattered or smashed by the
the news media so what do you think
about just
eradicating the concept of a bunch of
people going to the capitol building to
vote 700 and and dispersing the
the workload to the american people
so you're talking about an actual
democracy direct amendment or republic
that like we create like a smart
contract that our 700 000 people can
vote to decide if that contract is going
to toggle yes or no for certain things
so we still have some sort of
representative so it still requires that
that more people listen to tim paul's
podcast i mean what i mean by that is a
tape i'm serious though but if without
truth without without a a competently
informed intelligent discerning
electorate you're still going to get
you're still going to get bad policy but
so so this is uh i i disagree with ian
on this one but it is a really
interesting thought the idea is instead
of doing a direct democracy you do a
direct republic you still have districts
you still have electoral college but
instead of having a representative it
breaks down like an electoral vote
within the state so it doesn't matter if
you know if you have 750 000 people in
one area and you have 500 000 in another
it's it's still weighted you know what i
mean well that yeah so you should get
your senate there's the effect thereof
but it's it's hybridized i don't agree
with it you know i i i personally think
it's good to have reps there in person
doing their jobs but i do think it's an
interesting idea and i do think that you
know as technology changes and times
change we do need to be addressing how
this is going to affect legislation so
if this is like
you want to fix dc term limits for
staffers oh yeah yes right not because
the elected there is a bidding war when
an influential member retires over their
chief of staff
and that guy i mean i grew up in the
same neighborhood as a young man a young
man he's older than me who was who'd
been chief of staff for four or five
members great guy like not disparaging
him personally but he had a floor pass
right i mean like this guy's on the
floor of the house more influential by
far than a lot of people who've stood up
for election by 800 000 of their
constituents so term limits for staffers
once you hit gs 15 in an agency or what
have you you can be there this long and
you got to move because that's where the
secret power is and the second thing is
instead of allowing party leadership
because again political parties are the
poison that will destroy the the mix
um to determine committee assignments
let people draw lots for committee
assignments maybe you get you know if
there's 15 committees um maybe you get
15 sheets of paper to put in one bucket
and 14 and 13 and 12 because that's how
they bribe you if you want to be on this
committee ian
sheamus then you have to promise to vote
for the farm bill or not vote for
marijuana reform or what have you and so
in giving the leadership in both the
majority and minority the power to
appoint committees to provide committee
assignments you've just given them the
ability to blackmail every single member
what if you promise it and then don't
follow through with your promise then
you're done like they just won't work
with you they'll all ignore you in
congress there's always retribution for
any time that you betray the hierarchy
it's invisible or it's visible
what would you think because if they
didn't make you pay
everyone would disobey yeah what would
you think about uh removing party
affiliation from ballots
i don't have a problem with it again i
ran as a republican because it more
closely jived with my value set but my
value said is classical liberalism right
right i was listening to um
to a podcast that you and you were
talking to somebody about um
uh masking and and isolating in order to
preserve the most vulnerable and my
immediate knee jerk was what is the
responsibility of the most vulnerable to
protect the most vulnerable my immediate
knee jerk was what's the responsibility
the most vulnerable to protect
themselves amen yeah right and i'm not
saying like being considerate of your
grandma in fact you should be really
consider your grandma but
grandma's primary responsibility is
grandma right government starts as the
pinpoint center of a circle and radiates
outward from there so the the essence of
government is you then your family then
your neighbors then
yeah yeah the reason i bring up the
party affiliation thing is that people
will go into the ballot and they'll just
be democrat democrat democrat democrat
they don't know we're a republican
republican it's ignorant on both ends so
imagine what would happen if people just
go in and there's no party affiliation
to vote for it's just names so you know
we've talked about this before and one
response is people would just vote for
whoever was on the top of the list and
then everyone would fight people people
would change their name to like aaron
aardvark yeah well or people would just
vote for somebody if their name sounded
like they were from the same ethnic
background or something like that like
oh that's an irish name or oh that's an
asian name or whatever someone will
change their name with charizard
a bunch of people will vote guy's gonna
name it change his name to crash
lightning and everyone will be like he's
not for crash i'm voting for dc
people would like they would literally
no no deez nuts actually did well on a
ballot someone like put put it on the
ballot i'm not surprised he's like a
middle school kid and he pulled it off
wow
but so i there was this there was a
story in um i think it was new hampshire
of a trans anarchist satanist who ran as
a republican for in the sh in the
primary for sheriff and ended up winning
what but but uh i think it was like the
democrat democrat sheriff ended up
winning or something like that but a
bunch of republicans freaked out like i
voted for this person it's like well
yeah you checked the box joke's on you
dummy don't blame the person you voted
for if you voted for voting records so
you didn't know the name of the person
you didn't know what party it was but
you just got to see
all like or a bio you voted for a bio or
something yeah right then the devil
becomes who writes the bio i mean i've
checked my own wikipedia page
like under oath those are like under
oath bios like legal
verified and if you lie on your bio
there you go to prison kind of thing i
think we should let the same people
draft the politifact
like voting for a name or a party is so
insane look at what the media does you
know how they frame things to make them
negative it'll be like you know ian will
run into a burning building to save a
bunch of puppies who are trapped in the
top floor they'll show a picture of ian
standing in the fire holding the puppies
and it'll be like crazed man holds
puppies above flame and you're like well
that's technically true but he was
escaping the fire through the window
they'll just frame it however they want
so you get you know who's gonna write
the bio who's gonna who's gonna write
about the people
um it's just like during
one of my favorite examples of that
occurred during the written house case
when i believe his grace crits took the
stand
and what they were reporting on it i
can't remember which outlet it was but
he had brought a gun of his own to try
to protect himself from written house
even though what he had testified on the
stand was that he pulled a gun on kyle
before getting shot that yeah and he
lied and msnbc they were like he
testified that rittenhouse pulled the
weapon on him and then it was like
actually he testified he testified he
pulled the gun on rittenhouse and then
written house pointed the weapon so it's
just like the media just chooses to say
whatever they want because
i i don't think it's necessarily times v
sullivan that gives them this power the
fact is lawsuits are
very hard and they take
forever
and so look at it this way
they say sometimes they say often for a
lot of cops
process is the punishment new york city
is notorious for this the cops know they
can illegally arrest you but nothing
will ever be done about it so there's
nothing to worry about so uh
a good example is there was a
photographer in new york by the name of
alex arbuckle he was standing on the
sidewalk taking pictures of cops during
an occupy protest he actually had gone
down there to document it from the
police's side of things because he felt
the media was only covering the protest
perspective the police arrested him
filed a false police report and claimed
that he was obstructing a roadway the
officer who actually arrested him wasn't
the officer who claimed to to have
arrested him and who had signed the
arrest uh report and the officer who
wrote the who who signed the arrest
report wrote a fake account of what
happened fortunately i had been filming
and
the national lawyers guild i'm not big
fans of them but they got a hold of the
footage which proved the police lied
the police officer went on the stand and
lied under oath
not a single bad thing happened to any
of these officers but the cops know if
you're in their way they can arrest you
and you will go to jail even if for only
a day because that is the punishment for
defying them they know it can destroy
your life they know it can you get fired
from your job if you can't show up if
they arrest you on a weekend when you're
protesting you're there till monday they
know so this is this is a huge problem
we have when
lawsuits in this country move much too
slowly
so someone lies about you and you know
says like ian you know you kicked my dog
okay go ahead and sue him the story's
out it will perpetuate
so uh let's let's say there's a news
website called like the daily uh monster
the daily monster and they write a hit
piece about you claiming that uh you
stole someone's cat oh and it's
completely made up can you imagine the
most made up an insane story and you
know peop you know so you're like okay
maybe i should sue for defamation over
this knife first you gotta prove damn
proof damages what were the real damages
caused by this well what they've done to
project veritas is they've said his
reputation is so destroyed he's he's you
know he you can't make us you can't make
his reputation any worse thus we're now
allowed to lie and say whatever we want
the court rejected that idea but they
destroy your character so much that you
eventually you won't be able to
fundraise you won't be able to start a
business you won't be able to get
business partners people will be
terrified of you so you say i need to
sue over these lies the first thing that
happens is the court says times v
sullivan ian you're a public figure did
they know they were lying or
you know uh did their stand did their
standard in this procedure violate their
typical standards as my general
understanding for uh times v sullivan
let's say you get past all of that you
gotta get to actual malice too right so
their defense says well we didn't know
therefore they win well exactly that's
times v sullivan exactly as a public
figure it's um proving they knew they
were lying or
that what they did in this instance
violated their typical standards for
research
so if you can get past that
bro it's going to take you a million
dollars in a year
and then if you can't prove you lost
money because of it they're going to ask
you what are the damages and you can say
reputational my reputation is my
business and they can say prove it there
you you lose so it's not just times we
sullivan it's that
the media can lie with impunity and
nothing can be done about it nothing and
they do it all day they do it every day
they did it
you know seven days a week and twice on
sunday when it came to donald trump and
what do you do so like if i make a lie
like that am i do i have protections or
do i need to start a company called like
aardvark news and then just a website
aardvark news and then lie about you
under aardvark news and then i then i
have protection because i made a website
called aardvark news all that matters
is
you can defend yourself from a lawsuit
so when cnn are these big companies new
york times have billions of dollars they
will drop a a an anvil on you
metaphorically
so
i hope you're ready to defend yourself
can you do the same back
probably not probably not so project
veritas says has veritas legal where
they're trying that's a problem it's
this this attrition the war of attrition
when you are planning on losing anyway
you just want to drain the resources of
the other person and you know you have
way more resources so you can just wait
them out and you may still lose but
they're gonna like a pyrrhic victory
they might win on paper but because it's
the percentage of their army has been
decimated they've basically lost have
you guys ever played poker hold them oh
yeah yeah if you're if any if you no
hold'em if you've got the stack
you can you can pressure your opponent
yeah endlessly and force them out that's
exactly how it is in the real world you
put them all in every hand every hand
say you've got to risk everything you
have right now and i don't and i can do
it again seven times and you're just man
and they're putting in the blinds and
eventually they're getting eaten away
and they've got to take that risk and
then they take the wrong risk and
they're out but you can also win in
those situations and man does it feel
good to take someone's stack it does it
does but if you're if you know if you're
the last two in a game of hold them and
and you've got a smaller stack to the
guy's bigger stack lines
yeah eventually a blind is gonna be your
entire just a play you're gonna have to
bet everything
yeah so this is this is the challenge
hatchet harry's gonna take your dad's
bar you know that's right you're gonna
have to like throw your wedding ring
into the middle of the thing and then
the deed to your house well i have gems
but that's that's the big challenge is
as long as the media can just lie and
say whatever they want we we we stop all
this by not caring what the media i
don't know i also think we need to
change the laws it used to be that there
was some you know responsibility in nbc
cbs and abc that was it new york times
now it's joey joey macaroni or i'm sorry
if joey if you're out there just making
up a name
get started oh you wrecked it
at all news yeah
he can spin up a news organization
now yeah sorry joey i love you come on
the channel there there are clever
things you can do into your to your
question about starting aardvark news or
whatever and you probably said arvac
news because i mentioned aaron earlier
oh that's why yeah but um
so ian if you start a news organization
they'll still just sue you personally
and you may have a good chance of
winning
but you better fork up the 100k for that
initial defense so if someone at cnn
lies about you you can sue the person
that lied directly and not cnn yep is
that normally what happens you can sue
anyone joining them all but do you have
a better chance of winning against the
individual reporter or the entire issue
it entirely depends but uh you can go
after the individual and then they can
try and deflect typically what will
happen is the institution will offer up
the defense can you sue the institution
and the individual at the same time
yep
so uh cassandra fairbanks a good friend
of ours she held up the okay hand sign
in the white house which is just the
trump you know you know hey we're trump
supporters and a reporter accused her of
flashing a white supremacy hand gesture
she said that's not true it's defamation
she filed a suit it got thrown out on
motion to dismiss i guess because
they're like
like you yes i think what they said was
because she trolls on twitter then you
can't blame someone for believing you're
trolling or something for falling for a
troll or something like that yeah but
it's just the the news organization
defended the journalist the news
organization said we're going to pay for
the journalists defense so the
individuals who work for these big
companies with hundreds of millions of
dollars can say what they want and they
get away with it yeah exactly and so ian
you were sort of talking about possible
legal solutions a moment ago i think the
fact of the matter is even though
something like that would be good in
specific instances and there are really
great victory stories we were discussing
sandman yesterday
we've also been hearing that rittenhouse
is trying to go after some of these
networks that lied about him i think
that's fantastic but ultimately people
are waking up and there's a reason that
they have to write pieces and hit pieces
on people like joe rogan or tim and
that's because old media is scared
because people are paying more attention
to independent content creators and one
of the reasons for that is because it's
insane to get your information from
people who pay no price for lying to you
walk the dog backwards to the genesis
right and and so the genesis i think is
what they teach in j school and who
decides to be journalists
what's the role of the journalist
because jefferson talked about that that
fourth state and and the importance of
information to uh a free public
like there can't be one without the
other uh and so we've gotten away from i
want to be a storyteller too i want to
be an advocate i want to advance an
agenda and so
um what did
get off air you know aristotle
repeatedly said you give me the
storytellers i'll give you the future
dude these guys have studied on what
they're trying to do
and a lot of the parts of the machine
don't even realize they're part of the
machine but indeed they are
the the individuals these companies
don't know
uh what happens is there's a political
group and they'll say how can we get
more votes we need new stories in our
favor can we fund a news organization
yes the news organization then hires
people these people are business people
who want to make money they're told
here's our plan for making money hire
people who believe x y and z they then
go and fight find journalists who have
written stories about x y and z and say
how would you like a higher paying job
they get hired under the company no one
forces them to be cogs in the machine no
one forces them to write lies they find
people who are liars and idiots and hire
them and have them do more work or
they're not liars they they've drank the
proverbial drunk and the proverbial
kool-aid they just genuinely believe it
but like
your your formative years include your
higher ed right so university of
missouri and columbia these j schools
syracuse that put out like a
disproportionate share the orthodoxy is
in place yeah right and and dude man i
didn't become comfortable in my
dorkiness until i was 25 or later right
and i am now like i am who i am and i
like me would you know um
[Music]
these kids are are vulnerable so people
are saying this is it and there's
nothing else and they go okay this is it
there's nothing else yeah it's funny you
just mentioned a moment ago that some of
these people might not necessarily be
lying but they're on the same page as of
all as all of their colleagues and
that's unsurprising but at the same time
there was a great moment from chomsky
who i'm not a huge fan of but he made a
point when he was on an interview show
about how the dominant media culture
tends to do a spouse a specific set of
views and you can expect to hear a
certain number of you know legitimized
opinions from them and the reporter
responds to him by asking him do you
believe i'm insincere in my values and
chomsky said no i believe you sincerely
hold those i'm telling you you wouldn't
have this job if you didn't
that's brilliant yeah
yeah chomsky also said in the arena of
violence the uh the most brutal wins and
that's not us when he was condemning
that's right violence and writing so you
know the dude lost his plot later on but
he was pretty good back in the day too
he's a free speech guy i mean he's made
some good noises over here again not my
favorite not my favorite but he's made
some good noises yeah like quack and
what
let me let me let me show you how dark
this evil uh goes man i'm i've got no
problem calling evil i know that each
and every one of you who watch this show
will be shocked
but not surprised
the washington post published an opinion
piece which reads
canada must confront the toxic freedom
convoy head-on
you heard that right
the washington post has published an
opinion piece in opposition to working
class individuals standing up against
the elites because democracy dies in
darkness
let me show you this tweet sure does
this is a tweet from a political
cartoonist i believe from the washington
post michael de atter and it is a
cartoon of truckers with fascism written
on the sides of them i responded these
people think that when the working class
resists the elites it's fascism amen
that they do and they write this article
saying the convoy is by and large a
fringe group an unfortunate minority in
which the further minority of insidious
extremists lurk bolstered by
conservative politicians time and time
again we learn the lesson or at least
come across it that teaches us that rage
soaked anti-government types can't be
reasoned with this time around the
convoys produced an incoherent
memorandum of understanding premised
upon a misunderstanding of government
and absurd demands of course the memo
should be ignored it's the product of a
temper tantrum but doing nothing is a
risky sub-optimal strategy oh that's
right the working class of the problem i
guess this ridiculous article wasn't a
temper tantrum but these working-class
people trying to stand for their jobs
was also i love how he called them
fascist and then called them
anti-government i don't know that was
different okay the fascist was the
cartoon oh that's right you're right i'm
sorry i shouldn't confuse those i love
that cartoon and part of why is because
so as a political cartoonist you know
sometimes you swing and miss but i can't
imagine doing a cartoon where you like
literally just drew a picture and then
wrote bad on it
that's what he did
i'm going to draw trucks and write
fascism right
ben garrison yeah he even signed it like
ben garrison
he's just but ben garrison does label
everything
but at least they're still funny so i'd
so i i
checked the author david moscop wrote
that op-ed and um so about the author
david boskop is a political theorist
with an interest in democrat democratic
deliberation
what does that mean well i guess he
wants us to have democracy where we are
deliberative in our and our coming to
conclusions unless of course that
deliberately relationship leads to
conclusions that are adverse to david
moss cops at which point it becomes
fascism right
to me the irony is rich his his book is
too dumb for democracy so clearly he's
smarter than everybody else too
those daggone truckers are messing
everything up his book is called too
dumb for democracy it is well it's an
admission
was that his autobiography next week
next week's guest on tim cass david moss
no i don't know about that uh i just
think it's funny this this article is
like written by a a comic book villain
it's a bunch of buzzwords
the people are rising up against us they
want their rights those pathetic
truckers
anti-government types was that one of
the words that they used in here
anti-government types can you imagine
being you know it's something the
government does
it's a type but it's like they're not
even they're not even it's not even the
craziest person i've ever seen it's like
people driving trucks you know in the
united states when they burn that when
blm burns down whatever they're like
this is democracy it's like this is
people with jobs these people with jobs
like representing their jobs let's
juxtapose this headline on to
say antifa
burning a courthouse in portland we're
trying um these antifa protesters must
be confronted head on would be called an
incitement to violence oh yeah they
fired they fired that uh new york times
editor because he ran the op-ed from tom
cotton sending the troops or whatever
but uh
when you have when you have uh anti-fun
black lives matter engage in violence
what is it aoc like protests are
supposed to make you uncomfortable
like yo they literally killed people
dude i don't know it's a bit beyond
discomfort where does it say it's
supposed to be peaceful like i think
yeah that businesses were burned down
people's lives billions right like
billions of dollars who's leading the
company and those by the way those
places are are not going to recover for
a very long time i did uh so there's a
second youtube channel i run with the
foundation for economic education if you
guys want to check it out it's called
common sense soapbox and we did a video
on the riots and how much it's cost this
country and the communities it's
happened in in the long run and it's i
mean it's really astounding i have to
consult the figures again but i
recommend all you this is just and what
and what community says it happened in
exactly these are these are
socioeconomically challenged people who
the left says they champion who are
absolutely screwed by virtue of this
violence absolutely and and the people
who are who i mean
the greatest racism visited upon
americans today is is is failing schools
that
disproportionately impact what
socio-economically challenged people and
people of color right so but meanwhile
we're calling everybody in this room a
racist i actually give a damn i want
these young people to have a freaking
chance because that's what the promise
of america is it's not an outcome it's a
chance and also i and did interrupt you
and i apologize
but
before the show before i just met
sheamus he's like watch i'm gonna
interrupt you i did i was it was a point
it was premeditated interruption but
then they high-fived yeah
and then i interrupted him to apologize
oh good job good work
just just to loop this back into what
you were saying earlier about
republicans who are like but they'll
call us racist
do you i have to imagine there are
democrats who also have the same
mentality of we can't like so a better
example is when you mentioned uh the
obamacare repeal there are democrats who
are like we're gonna pass this bill to
help minorities don't actually vote for
it like in that video where aoc uh is
sitting down and then nancy pelosi walks
up to her and wiggles her arms on c-span
you don't know what they say but then
all of a sudden aoc changes their vote
things like that i'm sure they're
happening like no no no we have to
pretend like we just narrowly didn't get
this passed so we can earn votes so they
give leave to certain members in certain
districts to vote a certain way because
they think it might be politically
helpful dude i don't want anyone
representing me who won't vote the way
that they told me they were going to
vote when they ran for office
stribalism it's just that's what it is
it's it's
so my dad was a realtor and but his
political theory was like here's a
novelty tell people what you're going to
do and then try to do it
right and it'll work and you know for
i don't know 10 12 years in elected
office it did for me but yeah that's
that's gone right i mean we're hosed so
so tom can i ask you it sounds like
working within the system you saw a lot
of things that were very disillusioning
i'm curious
would you say that you became more
pessimistic about the political system
or did you maybe become more optimistic
about your ability to effect change
outside of it ultimately where would you
say it's placed dude um
so i'm on three committees i'm on
homeland security which is and this is
past tense but which is like the worst
committee there is it sounds super cool
but like they have no power because
everything's a turf war in dc and it's a
new committee so nobody relinquished any
power so we just go talk i'm on foreign
affairs which i fell in love with which
is where they go to warehouse the
pro-liberty people like how much harm
can a legislative branch guide do when
he's in an executive branch arena
foreign affairs and then i'm on
educational workforce and you go to
these committee meetings there's 50
members on the committee and somebody
fact checked me it's probably 51 or 49 i
don't know
but like normally there's five or six in
the room they come they do their two
minute talk they ask some questions they
leave right because we've gotten so far
beyond the enumerated powers envisioned
by the founders that nobody can carry
the bandwidth and they know nobody cares
which pisses me off because this stuff
matters
and so nobody's ever there micro comes
in from dirty jobs to speak to ed
workforce and he starts up by the way
when i grow up i don't know if i want to
be tim poole or micro yeah one of them
mike rowe is pretty rad he's pretty
great but so microwave starts off by
saying mike rowe and i'm a trained
professional opera singer and i know
nothing about it in workforce but i care
passionately about it right that's how
he starts
but every single but every single butt
is in c every democrats in the room
every republicans in the room and
they're all scrawling down what mike
rowe who starts his comments by saying
that i'm not an expert but i care about
this they're writing stuff down and i'm
and so that's when i thought like the
aristotle quote like you give me
storytellers i give you the future
and i'm hating washington from the
second day i'm there i'm like this place
is broken beyond my ability to fix it
and the coolest thing i've ever done is
like literally snatch people out of
prison against the will of the president
and the committee chair and everybody
because i wanted to do something
freaking mattered and i thought son of a
[ __ ] i can do more good telling stories
that aren't being told than i can ever
do in office that was the light bulb
moment and it wasn't like oh xl series
was born like i didn't know how to make
point a reach point b but i knew that
micro was more powerful than nancy
pelosi at that moment i could not tim
poole was more power no [ __ ] right i'm
not just kissing your butt um like
because
if you're loud enough and you scream
long enough washington will do something
but you have to tell the story but let
me tell you
cultural enforcement is more powerful
than law
so the way i explain it is that we have
a bunch of laws on the books that no one
ever enforces laws you can there's books
called like silly laws you know and
there's one where it's like you can't
put a pie on the windowsill on sundays
and it was passed in you know 1790
because some guy put a pile on the
windowsill attracted bears and then they
were like guys you got to stop putting
paws in the window so we're going to
write this down and now it's still on
the books right so we have these silly
laws but no cop is going to walk up to
you because you had a pie on the
windowsill and care about it at all but
hold on that law is on the books does
the cop just get to decide i won't
enforce that law the cop doesn't even
know the law exists so if the culture
changes it doesn't matter what a
politician says
yeah right why do people not beat their
wives hopefully
because you don't beat your wife because
it's a jackass horrible thing to do yeah
it's been illegal but that's why people
don't do it so you're exactly right but
we had a conversation a while back too
about cops choosing i think we had a cop
we had some you know former cops in the
show saying like well cops can't choose
what laws to enforce them like they
literally do every single day otherwise
they'd be arrested and some dude for
having a shower on a tuesday in in
massachusetts or whatever because these
laws are on the books but just as
important now there are sort of benign
the pie on the windowsill on sunday laws
that are still in the books but then
there are laws that are still in the
books
that are never going to be enforced
because they're horrible and the
politicians still lack the courage to
repeal them my favorite that i had
anything to do with was virginia had up
until 2016 a crimes against nature along
the books which made it illegal for
anyone to have any sex other than
missionary between a man and his wife it
was a freaking felony
it was a felony
to have any sex other than the
missionary between a man and his wife
and it was on the books it was a felony
and so in in 2005 cops enforcing it and
two but well they still
so this story in 2005 a democrat named
patsy tyser from northern virginia
carried a bill to repeal it and it
failed
and i'm like i'm the like i got a
evangelical biblical sort of
constituency but i'm looking at this
going this is horrible so i write the
repeal bill but i carved out to leave it
illegal if it was an adult and a minor
right because you know
and then the headline was garrett's
obsessed with teenage sex and i'm like
only when it's my teenager and you're 40
year old then you know we're locking
your butt up for that but we we took
that off the books because here's the
thing as a former prosecutor every law
that's on the books that's selectively
enforced or not enforced
waters down the meaning of every law
that's on the books that is enforced
because i as a rational thinking person
will go
why do i obey that while they don't
enforce exactly or they don't enforce
that one uniformly
but back to your point about you know
this show or any other show people need
to realize if
if tomorrow every single person woke up
and just said uh the us dollar is no
longer the currency i care about bitcoin
is then bitcoin is currency and the
dollar is worth nothing so long as the
system has confidence in it so these are
these are really important points for
people to understand the philosophy of
how our society works
when when republicans are like we're
going to get a bunch of judges appointed
i'm like wow that's completely
meaningless because when they come out
and they get a supreme court ruling the
federal judges won't really matter when
they come out and everyone on tv says
you're racist and then gop members are
like we can't pass that bill they'll
call us racist the cultural enforcement
is substantially stronger than any
statutory law yeah i remember having a
conversation with you a while ago i
think it was around the time we first
met but you made a good point that as
long as you change the language you
don't actually have to change law so i
think this was off the heels of the
civil rights laws being interpreted as
saying you had to
cater to certain delusions with respect
to transgenderism which is certainly not
what was intended back in the 1960s uh
but because our cultural understanding
shifted it was argued that this law was
actually uh meant to be enforced in a
very specific way
so just sorry interim but the specific
point you're everything just so people
and then i'll throw it back yeah but is
uh if the 1964 civil rights act says you
know you can't discriminate against the
basis of sex or whatever or they say you
know women have the right to x y and z
equal to men
if those laws on the books use the word
woman but then later on you have a major
cultural push to change the definition
of the word woman the law changes after
the fact exactly and i agree with so
this this wonderful aristotle quote
about storytelling
i wholeheartedly agree with that i
i think it's so important for people to
recognize that the best avenue for for
political and cultural change isn't just
political i mean that's part of it you
do want something there but it's really
shaping hearts and minds and this is a
huge part why a huge reason why i think
it's good to just stay away from
hollywood entertainment generally even
if there's not anything in it that you
think is particularly morally
objectionable a lot of these stories are
written by people who hate you and hate
your family and hate your way of life
and want to reshape the country and the
idea that the kinds of stories that they
tell aren't at all going to have their
worldview bleed into it and influence
you on some level is just ridiculous in
my opinion when you say they hate you
you mean the more that they your way of
life they they work counter to your your
belief in like what like because they
don't know you you're so they don't know
use an individual person but also the
idea well so let's say you have
a christian or a trump supporter or a
conservative who's listening to this
right now there are many screenwriters
in hollywood who would say i do hate
that type of person well that you said
they don't know you but they think they
know exactly exactly well that's exactly
uh going back to your reference of this
show and we can you know mention many
other shows be it you know ben shapiro
stephen crowder uh the pro-life movement
is a really good example there was this
really funny thing that happened we were
talking about where this democratic
congressman said if pro-lifers or if
republicans think that life begins a
conception then i'm going to pass a bill
that makes men
financially responsible for babies
starting a conception based
and they posted it
in this like leftist they posted it in
this you know like left a subreddit and
they were like ha ha that'll show these
conservatives and then all the
conservatives were sharing going like
this is awesome exactly that's how i
felt i was like this is fantastic yeah i
love that good make men responsible for
their children why would why would a
conservative who cares about the family
not want men to be responsible for their
children but this is the point they
think they know you exactly based on
media manipulation from people like
people like rachel maddow who lie who
make things up and not just people like
rachel maddow i think more importantly
the people who make films and television
shows who work conservative characters
into them who act so so the bill so the
sodomy bill rep repeal and i've over
characterized it i think it was less
broad than anything other than the
missionary between a men and women but a
friend of mine named adam evan who was
the first openly gay man in the virginia
senate he's a democrat i go to adam and
i'm like i'm going to do the sodomy bill
repeal i want you to co-patron it with
me he's like i can't it's your bill like
we're friends he's like and again i went
through the whole this is homophobic and
i'm like son of a [ __ ] i'm like trying
to like i mean like i'm the last guy who
cares what anybody does in their bedroom
right like that's between whomever
you're doing it with in god so long as
they're of age and with consent so yeah
man i mean we're going to paint this
however when a gay rva is a publication
out of richmond virginia and and one of
the guys comes to me and goes what
you're trying to do is this and i'm like
yeah he's oh dude i'm on your team i'm
like hello
it's really commendable
you actually made a bill to repeal
another law like i think these laws
should have sunset clauses built in so
you don't have to go through all the
effort it's just like virginia right we
had a bill on the books that says that
you can't marry somebody of a different
race wth right i mean like two human
beings who are in love right so what do
i want for my kids i want them to be
happy now i'm a person whose life has
been changed by god's grace that's my
belief instruction belief structure but
what i really want because happiness is
like more valuable than gold dude it's
it's so rare
there's there's a
probably an urban legend but they say
that uh is a reddit post it was like
when john lennon was a kid his teacher
said what do you want to be when he when
you grow up and he wrote down in his
assignment happy and the teacher said
you've misunderstood the assignment and
he said you've misunderstood life i
don't think he really did that no i
don't think i think i don't think john
lennon is that interesting i don't think
he would say something like that as a
child i think he might have actually it
is john lennon
hey he's made an interesting point that
cultural enforcement overweighs law and
i think that's because law is a type of
cultural enforcement it's just a
specific one but it's downstream yeah it
is it's like a little bit of it the
grand cultural enforcement is media you
see that so people are defining language
people say that like law and politics
are downstream of culture and there's
truth in that but i think it's much more
cyclical because the laws that we have
do influence the way people think so you
were mentioning this earlier about how
certain outdated laws on the books that
are that are no longer enforced or laws
that people don't care about actually
shape a person's understanding of other
laws and i think on some level we could
argue that that's cultural the law is a
teacher so
i don't want to get into a can of worms
here but like immigration whose fault is
it that two million people cross our
border illegally it's not theirs god
bless them okay i got kids to feed and
there's a wealthy opportunity zone to my
north that's tacitly encouraging me to
come like it's our fault i think any law
that's on the books that's not uniformly
enforced to the best of our ability to
enforce it should be off the books
or enforced
or changed
i agree with with these illegal
immigrants and i i respect them
infinitely more than these leftists in
this country who are like america it's
racist i'm like you got dude from south
america traveled two thousand miles
risking his life because he was like
america man and i'm gonna take care of
my family
it's like everything i've ever dreamed
of is coming to america because it's
it's it's a land of opportunity i don't
think they're coming here because
they're like oh free speech some of them
are some of them are like gangs will
kill me and the government will kill me
for speaking out i need to get to
america some of them are like the land
of opportunity where i can work hard and
succeed and then you've got these
millennials who are like but i don't
want to walk a dog longer than 20 you
know
cubans man i'm like okay we're gonna we
can we pick half a million people and
swap for half a million freedom loving
cubans
send the communists to cuba and bring
the cubans over here no yeah but then i
also i'd be remiss not to mention a
number of the people who are crossing
the border are those gang members who
the other people are crossing the border
are running from yeah my my underlying
point though is that it's nobody's fault
but our own right we have the where
we're going to force the laws we have
enforce them or change them yeah you see
that you said the story of that leaked
the the leaked video where the federal
contractor says
that he says the government has betrayed
the american people they were uh they're
they're secretly chartering illegal
immigrant flights
from texas around the country and taking
illegal immigrants across the border and
just shuffling them into other
communities and this cop confronts him
and he's like what's going on he's like
we're past curfew you're not supposed to
be here and the guy's like too bad we're
with the feds and the cops like well
that sucks and then the guy's like no
one's supposed to know about this so i
can't show you my my work id and the
cops like man that's crazy and he was
like but but why isn't anyone supposed
to know about it and the contractor goes
because the american people found out
the government betrayed the people
like he actually said that at least
we're not paying for the flights
oh wait we are
i got uh jorge ventura was on the show
he was down at the border watching them
deliver people across the border and
they have these these armbands on this
one says andrejas on it which means
deliveries this was on a child
um so they're they're it's straight up
it's real they're delivering uh human
bodies over here probably for slave
labor for i don't even think i don't
care why they're coming they're just
delivering them for money yeah
trafficking by the administration is
trafficking age migrants kids that's
that's a fact that is a fact yeah uh
they were cheap so in tennessee it was a
huge
outrage because these lawmakers found
out that the bright administration was
getting these military flights from air
force bases i think and and putting
underage migrants on them and
trafficking probably they probably think
they're doing good too like we're giving
them an opportunity but listen listen
they think they're engaging in a
political strategy that'll help them win
the coyotes these are the people who are
human traffickers
they're criminals many of them they
abuse and and harm children in very
extreme disgusting ways there's a story
of one guy just chucking a kid off a
boat into the river and just like a baby
i think it was
and the reason they're doing it and able
to do it is because the bite
administration has basically said if you
bring those people here we'll take care
of it for you livestock deliveries if
the administration said you show up we
got a pair of handcuffs with your name
on it they'd be like guys it's really
difficult to do this it's going to be
hard we can maybe do it with the button
administration being like come on down
and we'll get you a flight to wherever
you want to go
the coyotes the smugglers are like don't
worry it's really really easy you give
me a couple grand i'll get you to the
border the bite administration will take
care of everything for you that's why a
lot of these migrants are wearing shirts
they biden please let us in and he was
like uh okay
and did and that's what's going on they
should have put kamala please let us in
you know they should know their real
audience
yeah
yeah but that's why you know i look at
that i look at the the judges in the
pennsylvania story and i'm just like
the united states has been
eviscerated i don't even know if i can
blame like you were saying earlier you
blame us basically for letting this
happen i see migration as part of
our special history you know since the
dawn of time people have no one really
cares about the border unless it's a
river and you can't get across it um
well people have always cared about
borders yeah sorry
the point would be though that
you have to if you want to call yourself
a country be able to define that but
again
the the argument is always conflated
with that which cast your opponent in
the worst possible light right so what
we miss is illegal immigration right
there are real arguments to be made for
the amount of people in the workforce
and the needs of the workforce etc etc
and that they might be addressed by
loosening and tightening the flow of
inflow right we're lucky enough
somewhere where people want to come but
all that's lost you hate these people
because right and then it's parroted
from the hilltops the mountaintops by
sort of a complicit messaging
organization that's job literally is to
do that so very interesting when you're
standing at the wall saying you can't
come in and they're like starving and
begging you and you're like it's for
your own good and for my own good you
cannot come and they're like please god
let me in and you're just like no well
it's the responsibility of a nation
state to ensure the needs of its people
are met first and foremost i believe
that you should as a country care for
the needs of others if possible but you
can't do it at the expense of the
well-being of your own people it's very
complicated let me ask you a question
tom uh because you've spent time in the
middle east how does the united states
respond to uh american citizens being
held hostage for ransom when i mean like
truly there's there's a timeline here
because how many people are still
sitting in afghanistan
i i know americans
but let's let's say let's say a
terrorist organization
you know uh surrounds a vehicle with
some americans in it captures them and
then set and then you know makes a
ransom demand we want four million
dollars right historically you don't
negotiate with terrorists so what does
the us typically do
again it's when i mean you see you had
the uh missionaries uh
kidnapped in haiti recently and i can't
get into the backstory on how that
release was secured but you know the
protocols change over time is all i can
say
um
and and you know
what i used to say with young young
children was you can't feed the monster
because if you feed the monster it's
hungrier next time so uh do you know
what spain and germany are known for
doing when their citizens are taken
hostage
no
they just pay it yeah so uh
i did i did hustle environment training
this is this is years ago now this is uh
uh six years ago so maybe maybe protocol
has changed but what we were told and
what i've what i've learned and
generally my travels you know going to
like turkey and stuff the united states
doesn't negotiate with terrorists and
they basically say
these guys in these countries know that
if they take you and find out you're an
american citizen they'll typically be
like get away from me kill me because
the americans
you know some black helicopters will be
over your house you know over your over
your building in
in a day or two and they'll kill you and
your family so it's
it's it's it's the israeli response to
munich right and and what it does is it
begets less of that in the future but
i'm telling you
without saying stuff that i can't say
because i might compromise the safety of
people who i hold in high regard and
without saying stuff that might keep
your podcast from getting ganked
um
that
the paradigm may have shifted even worse
we're giving money to people who are
holding americans without
getting anything for it right i mean i i
believe by golly if you're going to give
them 600 million palletized dollars then
you at least ought to get something in
exchange for it yeah i would i would
absolutely believe that in the in the
current political climate but just just
uh to finish that point off
what we were told was we did a training
where they kidnapped us they blindfolded
us it was like three hours it was really
crazy because it felt like 10 minutes
and they bring you in blindfolded and
they play those weird noises going
around this whole big warehouse you're
in then they bring you into a room with
a light in your face and you can't see
anything and they ask you a bunch of
weird questions
and then all of a sudden the doors bang
open and you hear screaming on the
ground now hands on your head on your
everyone does it then you get picked up
now what you'll learn after the fact is
these guys are the americans rescuing
rescuing you
and what they said was these are these
are like former intelligence guys these
are former uh like special forces and
they're like if they were like if any of
you
you know we're all americans are
kidnapped
play it safe stay alive you will be
rescued
however you know you you probably they
said the pro the likelihood that u.s
americans get kidnapped is lower because
americans will execute the individuals
who kidnap you and their families it is
extremely brutal when they kick that
door in
nobody nobody rescued daniel pearl i
mean it's you know i mean
you think they let that guy get killed
for propaganda no not i don't at all i
think that uh that historically we've
tried to create a scenario that
disincentivized bad behavior
uh but
you know when you don't have boots on
the ground yeah um
sometimes people get beheaded on video
what they said was spain and germany
just pay the ransoms so they're
they they they hunt these people down
basically they created a market for it
they created a market to buy their own
citizens back it's insane the story we
were told on this show that there was
like some town in india that had a snake
problem so the government said that was
your story yeah yes that's also that's
another video i did for the foundation
for economic education this is known as
the cobra problem so basically
i believe it was in um british occupied
india
there was a snake problem there were
cobras and so
it was said by the british government
that anyone who brings us a cobra tell
will be paid and they thought this is
going to help us eliminate the cobra
population well what actually happened
was people started cobra breeding
operations and then started killing the
cobras and bringing their tails and the
problem got worse
it's amazing that's another stupid bill
so we had no hunting on sundays in
virginia but we were paying bounties for
people to kill coyotes except if you
killed a coyote on a sunday you'd
committed a crime and i'm like hang on
we're spending tax dollars to
incentivize this six days a week but
we're prosecuting people for doing it on
the seventh
and again coming from somebody who's
saved by grace like you know i'm a
christian but like
explain to me this law again you know
you were saying earlier that our
behavior towards terrorism how we deal
with terrorists changes and i i see that
like in afghanistan they say we don't
negotiate with terrorists yet we will
surrender to them
terrorist changes because 20 years ago
the idea that we would be placating the
taliban and sending them money while
there were literally hundreds of
americans
who are being held against their will
despite what saki tells us in
afghanistan is is unthinkable and and
and oh biden's approval ratings are low
not as low as they'd be if we still
define terrorists the same way we did 20
years ago do you have evidence that
there are americans they're being held i
know yeah i know people who've been into
americans who've been in afghanistan
subsequent to august
right and again careful what i say but
you know what they're doing pulling out
americans now and that's without the
security provided by the american
government god bless them so i so want
to talk about exile series because these
are the guys that yeah well let's let's
let's talk about this here's what we
have this uh indiegogo you launched and
here's what i find truly interesting
about this so this is your exile
documentary series exposing the global
crisis of religious and ethnic
persecution but the first thing i want
to talk to you about is
you're trying to shop this documentary
series around to these networks
and they're telling you outright
yeah but can you do it without
criticizing china so they're telling us
two things hey that's good product and
then secondly can you do it without and
so it's hey that's a good product can
you do it without talking about china
and secondarily the gulf states and um
i'm like so my exact words the first
time i heard this were you know we could
do a beetle stock without talking about
john but it would suck um so what what
so first tell us what this is like give
us the elevator pitch and what it's
about and then you know why why china
you know why they're upset about your
christmas no human being should have to
live in the place of their birth with
fear that stems from their faith their
ethnicity or race their sexuality or
what have you this is a human
fundamental right to live without fear
in the place of your birth now if you
want to move move i was in syria
speaking to some members of the
christian community from the cabaret
river valley and a representative and i
said if i could give you anything which
i can't that you want what would it be
and he's like send all the christians
back and i'm like hell no no never
but i would like to help make a world
where they didn't have to fight like
hell to leave to begin with right nobody
should have to live in fear based on
deeply held convictions or immutable
character traits
yeah pause for dramatic effect that's it
so so why why do we live in a world
where where eighty percent of the world
lives in fear of religious persecution
which we do eight out of ten people
right that's four out of five for those
of you who went to same school i did um
and i i i just that's because nobody
freaking knows i try to point out i i i
feel for the white male christians in
this country who are suffering the worst
i'm looking over at sheamus he's looking
directly out
but wait a white irish what are you
talking about yeah
but yeah so so
i just kind of backed into this and i
and i'm still friends with some people
in dc shockingly and and these guys and
gals don't know this stuff nobody knows
this stuff but if we understood just how
bad this is right i wish you guys could
i mean
in three and a half minutes we kind of
sort of shine a light on how bad this is
how pervasive it is and and the other
thing is like we talked again off air
hubris is when you say it can't happen
here that's like the last thing anybody
says the titanic can't sink it's
unsinkable
oh [ __ ] right this boat's in trouble and
so we want to show these stories because
all too often the west the united states
even and i love this country right i've
served it in uniform i've served it
locally state and federally and it's not
as cool as it sounds um but the united
states has all too often been complicit
we've either turned a blind eye or
actually helped the people who were
hurting their minority populations oh
yeah definitely well so so i definitely
want to get into that
but in detail but uh how is it that you
know china plays a role in this and and
why is it that i mean i imagine you
criticize america to a certain degree i
just did right but so so are these
networks being like oh don't criticize
america no they're saying don't
criticize china well because in america
you can criticize america but in china
you can't criticize china right in
america you can't criticize right
apparently right um in fact there's a
cottage industry built around keeping
americans from criticizing china um
irony shout out to mark cuban everybody
right and everybody wants
we should boycott the beijing olympia
it's like maybe we should but that ship
has sailed what would be freaking
awesome is for one of these amazing
young men and women who's worked their
whole lives to be so good at this is to
earn a gold medal to use that podium in
beijing to stand up for freedom and
human dignity
right well that's not boycott jesse
owens jesse owens sent the biggest
possible message to the nazis when he
kept winning gold medals but didn't they
ban protest outright so like no black
lives matter stuff no anti-china stuff
they got to have a medal ceremony right
who were the guys in in was it 68 who
raised their fists right my i i
personally would i think they should
boycott it you know i mean
i think they might should have but it's
too late we could have replicated this
we're pouring money and and fuel onto
the propaganda fire that is the ccp that
that that is literally so i'm doing a
fox news interview right you think
they're playing to the right and they go
well on the screen are the 10 biggest
defenders of religious freedom and i'm
like oh how do you have that list
without china on it wow i mean
everybody's weaker muslims yeah dude
it's the uyghurs of the tip of the
iceberg so they've been organ harvesting
from the fulangang in china for for
decades there's there's two churches in
china there's the state sanctioned
church that does as they're told and
then there are the people who huddle it
and this is not hyperbolic who huddle in
fear in in in their kitchens in groups
of two three five
because they want to actually learn the
gospel right so the chinese are the
absolute worst because why because for
communism and totalitarianism to succeed
the state must be paramount and faith
whether it's judaism or islam or
christianity says that there's something
bigger than you and me and indeed the
state and the government jesus was such
a threat to the empire dude right and
and and so they they had this the script
for how jesus was supposed to play and
he didn't play by it and it's also why
in north korea they're told that what is
it kim kim il-sung or whatever created
the universe or something like that yeah
is that true right divine i read that i
don't actually know but we did have um
yeah we had young me on right now
did she did you talk about that i can't
remember the specific details on what
they what they're told to believe yeah
all i know is that she came out of there
not knowing what love was because they
had so thoroughly brainwashed her and
there's no chance of developing any kind
of faith outside the state in a place
like north korea where are some of the
hot spots around the globe as you've
been studying this so nigeria's been
horrible for 20 years and it's never
talked about right again like
i served uh in the military i did uh
eight months in a tent in bosnia during
operation joint guard joint endeavor
largely because christiano allen poor
told us truly and she was right how
horrible it was when 8 000 muslims were
massacred at srebrenica
and half a million people are murdered
in rwanda over ethnicity before the u.s
and the world get up off their hands
right so so africa is terrible there's
like a line of blood across africa as
radical islam and not islam i have
wonderful muslim friends who have helped
me not die
um sort of creeps southward um myanmar
burma is is one of the worst so in in
this the second world war we promised
the burmese minority groups which is
about 45 of the country you get 55
percent uh berman's and then you've got
kachen and wah and karen all these
ethnic tribes which are either muslim or
christian
and and so the the burmese had never
lost a fight the british came in
subjugated them the japanese came in the
burmese are like let's get the british
out we're on your team the minorities
the british and the americans go to the
minorities and go if you help us get the
japanese out we'll make sure you have
autonomy and self-determination when we
win and they did they fought bled and
died next to americans and british
soldiers and then the war ended and we
said yes well anyway and left and the
burmese civil war started in like 1947
and it's still ongoing right
right and so you hear about the rohingya
but also there are the kachen and the
wall and the koran and and so this has
been going on for generations um
south asia is horrific right modi has
absolutely weaponized faith because he
understands that even though they have
240 million muslims and millions of
christians and even a jewish community
etc in india that they've got 870
million hindus so it's a big we they
paradigm
if you're an amity muslim in pakistan
that is muslims who believe that there
have been subsequent prophets after the
prophet muhammad you'll be murdered in
public and often without recourse if
you're a christian in pakistan uh the
christians in afghanistan now and these
we're talking about tiny slivers right
again the formulaic sort of totalitarian
game is to pick a minority group big
enough that everybody thinks they know
somebody from it but small enough that
it can't defend itself what are they
doing to the christians in pakistan
driving them underground right there was
a great uh story about a pastor sahil
latif who uh i was able to tangentially
help
who was locked up because he was
advocating for the rights of the
impoverished in karachi not just
christians but muslims as land grabbers
came in saying oh this is the next place
that we want to invest and then
systematically essentially did title
fraud on all these people who had like
ten square feet and so sahil latif
speaking up for him and they put him in
prison and shut down his church right so
like it's brave just to be a christian
there
to be a christian who stands up and
leads so it's even it's even it's
arguably stupid but the backstory was
when he got out immediately they said
well you need to move i mean
he shouldn't have to move right so
that's exile is if we tell these stories
right i'm the naive guy because it's a
lot easier to be naive than than to be
worldly
i if we tell these stories i think that
that the people of the west won't
tolerate it if the people of the west
demand their leaders act differently
then they will act differently and if
they do act differently we can change
the world without putting boots on the
ground without spending money
do you want to do economic and security
business with the u.s you do good then
stop throwing your homosexuals off
rooftops dumbass right stop persecuting
your christians stop displacing your
muslims when george bush jr invaded
afghanistan and then all of a sudden we
had this muslim pro it was a problem
with muslim it was all of a sudden it
felt very racist towards muslims in
islam there's a lot of hate 2003 4-5
what did we have a sikh that was shot
because an idiot thought he was a muslim
so how do we being implicit in that
because sometimes i'm like take the
plank out of your own eye before you try
and fix your neighbor like
there's a definitely some sort of
problem here in the united states
obvious it's global it's beyond nation
oh yeah no yeah how do we kind of unwind
our own races do you see it anyway as
part of the same problem like we need to
so if we are able to do exile at
excelsiors.com if we are able to do
exile we'll do an episode here in this
country because we do have very real
problems with prejudice and
discrimination right they're not
necessarily would have been identified
by the groups that claim to speak for
the oppressed groups um
but this is this is so simple and again
we i think off air talked about like
well they say it's too simple i think
we've overcomplicated things
you simply say that as a point of entry
to do economic or security business with
the us you have to pass these these
civil rights criteria you may not
segregate or or or or disallow the
participation of any group based on you
know
sexuality race religion etc and and as a
and i think it works because the world
has to choose between getting in camp
with the west in the u.s or china and
china doesn't they don't borrow they
take right it might look like borrowing
so i think it works the the example i
always like to use is turkey during the
cold war i think i already spoke to this
so we needed to control the bosphorus
right because we need to keep the
soviets black sea fleet from sneaking
down in the mediterranean and wreaking
havoc in europe so we said turkey we
want you on our team and they said cool
we want to be on your team meanwhile
they're persecuting their christian
community they're absolutely decimating
their kurdish community they passed a
law these are our nato allies the turks
who subsequently in the last five years
actually put under siege a u.s base and
held americans hostage and it never made
the news
where there were new
technical nuclear weapons but i digress
so they passed a law that said there's
no such thing as occurred and the u.s
didn't do a darn thing about it i'm
going to guess that if you say to turkey
you can go be with the soviets or you
can be with us but the price of being
with us is not oppressing your
minorities that they're still with us
i take that gamble there's there's
challenges in um
you know how much the united states
should be policing other countries so i
think boots on the ground i would always
be opposed to right but then there's the
question of us knowing what's going on
in china with the uyghur muslims and
then doing business with them anyway
right and people like mark hugh mark
cuban and lebron james being like oh we
gotta stop insulting china and it's like
no no no no no like dude we don't we
don't want to go invade china or
anything like that but we don't need to
like be buying stuff made in xinjiang so
my head's gonna explode right because
people go oh muslims dude isis killed
more muslims than they did christians or
yazidis right it ain't even close
so and people go oh you're insulting
china you know who suffers the most
under the chinese regime
the freaking chinese
right so don't tell me that by me
speaking out against an authoritarian
regime that stymies their compete their
people as it suits them i'm anti-chinese
i'm anti-oppression we we do have uh you
know these amount of viewers i have a
lot of friends who are very much proud
isolationists they're like nope
america's for america we should focus on
america we gotta not be involved in that
stuff and i don't agree um i'm not you
know i think there's a there's a there's
a happy medium between like boots on the
ground in a foreign country because
they're concentration camps like china
and hey china we decided not to buy
those you know cloths from you because
you have concentration camps this is
totally liberty based foreign policy it
really is i'm not advocating for boots
on the ground anywhere i'm advocating
for not doing business with oppressors
right now things will happen that we
will not know about and things will
happen on varying scales and and
certainly hard and fast rules are tough
sometimes but we have absolutely
positively turned a blonde eye over
decades and the world knows it if and
this should like here's the thing
i'm tired of the partisan back and forth
rhetoric that are wrong and we're right
and this and that and the other we
should be able to unite under the idea
right this is what exiles series.com is
all about
that you should be able to live in the
place of your birth without fear left
and right should be to get behind that
and if the cost of it is that we choose
to do business with people who treat
their minority groups and their majority
with basic human dignity right
who who can who can't get behind that
well but we don't because nobody's ever
said i guess then the solution or maybe
you're suggesting the economic sanctions
against countries no just don't do
business with them yeah i guess that's
talking about instead of the government
it's more of an individual choice like
you're inspiring individuals so i so
when i buy a clock radio i i to this day
and i don't buy clock radios anymore
because it's 20 22 but i'm old but so
when i buy a product to this day i'm
gonna look on the box and try to
ascertain where it's made and if i can
buy a product that's made in malaysia
before i buy a product that's made in
china i'm buying the product made in
malaysia and if i can buy a product
that's made in the united states and i
pay a little bit more to be fair i'm
going to buy that one too um
when i was in the military i used to say
i don't want to pay for the bullet that
might be used to shoot me because
another little secret of the chinese is
the actual military apparatus owns a lot
of the means of production so you could
if you're in the american military and
you're buying products made in china you
ironically enough are
paying for weapons that will be pointed
at you
so yeah it starts with the individual or
if you're a taxpayer i mean just with
all the coups that we funded and
everything that's gone in the middle
east and how we end up fighting rebel
groups that we funded so it's like yeah
ultimately american troops are just
going to inevitably be shot with bullets
that they paid for it's pretty insane
and without gratuitously piling onto the
debacle that was the afghanistan
withdrawal it is not a question of if
but when americans are killed with
american weapons yeah i mean it's not
it's gonna happen if it hasn't it's
already furious obama's whole
cartel's guns thing man talk about
failed leadership they've literally
prioritized the political agenda over
the lives of their very citizens
and and in the case of what we're trying
to address at exilesseries.com they've
politicized profit over the lives of
their fellow human nobody cares about
the uyghurs was refreshing because
somebody told the truth
and
the co-owner of the golden state
warriors
people were ragged on that guy because
they were like how dare you say that and
i'm like what be honest with everyone he
didn't say i personally don't care about
their plight he said come on nobody
cares about this let's be honest which
is right and i'm like nobody that should
be the clarion call they buried the lead
yeah we we talk about you know uh the
weaker muslims concentration camps
fairly frequently and it's it's
remarkable how for one a lot of people
don't know and a lot of people do
literally don't care and i'm you know
like i said look i know it's not easy
for the average person to find that
solution but try to buy american even if
it costs a little more and there's a
happy medium like i said between
invading the country declaring war and
just being like you know you shot that
disney movie
in the province with the security forces
of concentration camps we're not going
to watch that movie no but people don't
don't know or care yeah well and if
everything i was discussing earlier you
know the fact that these hollywood
screenwriters and executives at these
studios actually hate you and your way
of life isn't enough to encourage you to
stop purchasing their products
they're also in league and catering to
people who are running actual
concentration camps for real right yeah
i mean like that's not hyperbolic that's
not hyperbolic so you asked earlier um
what's the elevator pitch and of course
i would like to wait 20 minutes to
answer questions
the elevator pitch is hollywood won't
make this movie
this the stock series they won't and if
you go to excel series.com shameless
plug and you click on that trailer and
you don't think that's freaking
world-class product right to tell these
stories
it may be the best but you did insult
china so i'm sorry we can't fund your
project it reminds me of like a vice
stock in the early days of ice and they
were just like one of the darkest places
how much money can we make if we air
this we can make money how much money
can we lose if we air this we could lose
more
what's the right thing to do make money
holy crap we're screwed right that's
where we are and it's just i mean like
can you believe it that's not that's not
rhetoric if we're in you believe it if
we're at the point where
and we are where these big networks are
like let's make a movie but don't offend
china china's winning china's one and
then and then what i mean they're
they're they're some of the worst human
rights abusers on the planet what was it
khrushchev and i'm gonna butcher the
quote who said i will you will
manufacture the rope that we use to hang
you yeah right again when money drives
you with money and not justice and that
which is right drives you
it's like the free hong kong stuff you
know when the nba wouldn't allow you to
make a free hong kong jersey to order
or the hearthstone player it's a card
game held up free hong kong and they're
like get them out of there and you know
there was look i do think there's some
rational argument and keep politics out
of some of these things
but
when the nba can't like you're trying to
buy a custom jersey for yourself and
you're like i want free hunk i'm like no
or there was that guy who got kicked out
because he had the free hong kong sign
at the nba like yo american corporations
it's i'll even say this
it's one thing
if you are like mark cuban actively
defending china it's one thing if you
are like
you know
look we don't want politics in here and
then it's it's funny when an american
corporation is actively defending china
from protesters in america like that is
just a whole new level scorpion is what
it's communism and cooperative yeah
right remember
you can use that one man yeah that's
great corpianism
well so like the left used to rail
against the corporations and now their
agenda is funded by and at some level
dictated by the corporations but we
won't go down that road um and they used
to stand up for free speech and now you
know you must adhere to the orthodoxy i
mean like
it's it's dystopian it's remarkable how
uh
you know one of the points brought up by
one of our super chatters the other the
other day was that they say black people
can't be racist but candace owens is
racist exactly i don't i don't i i'm
lost man you know i i i get it it makes
no sense on purpose i suppose but sure
whatever when i went into sudan against
everyone's wishes and and and snatched
these two guys out and met him at the
airport i didn't take a camera crew
because i'm a crappy politician right
because i felt like it would be dirty to
do that but meanwhile i'm being called a
racist it just it just baffles me like
i'm literally risking my life again and
again and again as as a white christian
male 1 for for for for people of
different races ethnicities and faiths i
wonder how many and i'm being called a
racist how many and throughout time have
been demonized that are actually did
good and like lucifer let's take the
worst demon of all
how how do you know that he was evil the
because history told you he did wrong
yes people talk because you're a racist
i can't stand the way propaganda works
against individuals the way they try and
tear people maybe i just thought you
were going to do the olinsky book for us
no but i think it'd be fascinating to
see you both do like your own
conversation on religion
you know hippie ian dmt spirituality
with you know sheamus christianity and
have that conversation and
you know be fascinating yeah it doesn't
have to be about the christian bible i
know that the bible is very divisive
about good and evil so i wonder if like
i think of that as propaganda too do you
think that's evil
what probably the bible's true about
good and evil oh yeah if the catholic
church actually devised a plan to
manipulate people that's evil well no
but you're saying it's too divisive
about good and evil is it like what's
wrong with being divided like what's
wrong with talking good and evil because
you if you're the one that gets to
decide what's good and what's evil and
you tell people like this is evil don't
then you're controlling people's
behavior but you're saying what the
church is doing is evil
from hollywood but i've already made a
lock stock reference earlier and i'm
about to quote kaiser so say so right
the greatest trick that the devil ever
pulled is convincing us he didn't exist
amen so until you can until you can
identify some baseline for right and
wrong right
liberty is ultimately allowing your
freedom stops where mine starts allowing
people to make any decision they want to
for themselves until it begins to impact
others
and so um
what i'm advocating for is a world where
and we can all do that
but when you start hurting other people
then we have a duty i think particularly
people lucky enough to be born here to
say no no i can't i can't support it
we're literally supporting it that's the
thing it's it's not even a question of
going over there and do some doing
something it's just a question of not
supporting it so here oh should we go
intervene in ukraine hell no but we
should let the ukrainians help
themselves
all right let's go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
give it a nice little tap that thumbs up
it's greatly appreciated subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends if you really want to help us
out and go to timcast.com become a
member to get access to exclusive
members only segments from all of our
guests really awesome shows it's a huge
library of content you don't want to
miss but let's read what y'all have to
say
all right let's see
cheeseburger says arguing with ian be
like jelly wrestling an eel
that's a wonderful
bunch of noises that someone did tim
just made
all right
uh james tefferson says hello i'm from
pa and appreciate you covering this news
as actual journalists with a broader
perspective than the local stations no
offense to them what are your thoughts
on governor tom wolf didn't he kill a
bunch of old people i think he did too
yeah yeah sounds like not a good guy
yeah so
all right bradley heaton says big fan i
think you use the term objective
incorrectly objective evil can only
exist if a creator exists objective evil
would be any against that entity human
evil is subjective objective is without
emotion we can subjectively determine
evil
i don't uh i i your point taken but i
don't think i used objectively wrong um
but i do think you know i can clarify
this was on the member segment i think
we were talking about this and my point
is
in the human experience there is evil
that is universal to all humans you all
humans can identify certain things as
evil that's my point yeah i mean we have
certain moral intuitions and again human
perception doesn't define whether
something is good or evil but i think
it's a good point because we wouldn't
say for example um if every single
person in this room was able to observe
that there was this water bottle here we
wouldn't say well but we don't actually
know for sure the water bottle's there
because our senses could be deceiving us
yet we tend to do the same thing with
morality
yeah yeah yeah right so the baseline
again is when do you start to harm
others right you can do whatever you
want until you do my liberty stops where
this begins well i think for i think for
a libertarian analysis but i would also
say with morality we have an obligation
not to harm ourselves and to take care
of ourselves et cetera i'm thinking
about it from the perspective of the ccp
like are they saying the uyghurs are
harming us by existing just their
behavior their existence is a threat to
our
our species their value structure is a
threat to to the regime right so i think
they're the borg and they're evil
yeah that's what it looks like from this
perspective the ccp is the borg
that's kind of how i see it but from
their perspective
the the uyghurs are a threat to their
way of life another thing that's been
going on is back before they got rid of
their one child policy they weren't here
adhering to it in the rural outlying
areas anyway and the chinese are the han
chinese are like if you want real racism
right so the uyghurs aren't han chinese
and uh they don't want more it's those
people thing with them but yeah let's
read some more we got eraftis of stet
hey sheamus mormon here just wanted to
say that polygamy hasn't been practiced
with the church's approval since 1890
and divorce isn't legal either i think
it's important to remember churches are
made up of the same flawed humans
yeah definitely i would i'd have to
defer to carry on that if she were still
here according to a lot of people i've
spoken to who either were firm former
mormons it's something that has occurred
but not necessarily within the church or
not something that the church endorses
anymore um i think i think the fact that
you have to like go back on a teaching
and this is with all due respect by the
way because i actually do appreciate
your super chat and i'm not just like
here to bludgeon you for disagreeing
with me and obviously you know more
about mormonism than i do and there's
there's plenty i could learn about it
from you but i would say that a church
having to say we speak for god but god
was wrong about this or we were wrong
about this as an indicator that it's not
the true church so for it to change its
position on polygamy is actually
condemning in and of itself
but what you're saying that if any kind
of church reforms then if that is
satanic that is evil so if the church
it's panic i don't know if that's wrong
so no it's a good question because there
can sort of be like administrative
changes or there can be changes in terms
of what practices are occurring but if
if a religion says this is immutable
morality from god and then later on they
change it
then they're basically saying either a
god changed his mind and i believe that
that's an incoherent idea um or
b like god changed his mind about
fundamental morality or b we got it
wrong in the first place in which case
why do you trust them to get it right
now did you think that lutheranism was a
heresy absolutely yeah that's why it's
called lutheranism the catholic church
names a heresy after the person who
started it generally speaking so that's
why lutheranism is called lutheranism
actually luther called himself a
reformer and actually called himself a
catholic the catholic church called him
a lutheran and his followers lutherans
interesting yeah all right well you guys
should have a longer conversation on
this yeah but let's read it but by the
way thank you for your super chat too
because i i do appreciate being
challenged and having these kinds of
discussions all right vbdc says where in
west virginia is fridamastan nice try
and when does tim cast music launch can
i help run it i've had a number one
reggae album on itunes a couple weeks
ago uh purebloods ps no ian we fleeing
um i love that we we're producing music
i just recorded scratch track uh vocals
for for one song we're putting together
fairly rough i just did like two takes
and there are a few sour notes in there
you know what happens like i'm not uh
i'm not the greatest singer in the world
or anything like that but i can i can
get it just to take me like you know six
or seven takes to get a good run through
and we should be having a few songs
coming out soon i think we might even
have like we might end up with like five
songs all at once ready to go and then
make some videos for him and uh
we're talking with some of our good
friends about producing music one of the
things i really want to do is send one
of our tracks to uh the daily wire and
see if ben shapiro could drop some
violin on it
i'm not even kidding and then uh you
know like sydney watson plays piano and
sings and then jack pasok plays bass and
uh james o'keefe sings so i'm like why
don't we just like ask people to do a
quick recording and then we'll throw it
in the mix and then we'll have this
crazy song of all of these different you
know people first of all you should
invite bench prior to rap yes all right
secondly you should have invited me to
play harmonica but i get it you don't
love me oh
yeah i mean if we if ben shapiro was
down to rap on a song
i would i would be it would be an honor
and a privilege even if you pause to
think about it
[Music]
gangster's paradise
oh my god
all right
okay gang
does he say that all the time honestly
okay thanks here's the thing okay yeah
he says a lot can you do can you combine
jordan peterson and ben shapiro yeah
i've actually done that before
so
yeah so so um we can either do like
shapiro's voice with peterson's cadence
or uh peterson's voice so like honestly
if you're going to tell me that
universal healthcare is a good idea for
america you're wasting my time
okay gang
okay
[Laughter]
all right all right all right dj white
says what if we removed names and
parties from the ballot and instead put
issues on the ballot and whomever
matches the position on that issue gets
the vote make their positions known
though uh because primaries would be
confusing you'd have like a big list of
pro-choice it would be like one
pro-choice two pro-choice three
pro-choice and you'd be like i don't
know the second one i guess and then who
are you voting for who puts the gun on
their head and makes them keep their
word yeah right
maybe that's metaphorically just so we
don't well we we we talked about this
we talked about ian proposed arresting
politicians who signed bills without
reading them interesting yeah
i had a bill called the read it act
because they dropped like 20 000 pages
on us and said we're going to go in
tomorrow and vote on it and so read it
act stood for review every review every
enactment
uh
detailed and total or something that's
starting to be clever dude i couldn't of
course i couldn't get a vote on that one
either yeah
so what the bill said was that we were
entitled to without sleep five minutes
per page or or one minute per page per
piece of legislation before it was
brought to a vote and it was like what
are you trying to do without sleep we
have to yeah without including sleeper
trips in the bathroom right what they
give why would they do that that must be
because they want to ramrod it through
of course it's not because they want to
ram right through and if anybody stands
up and says that in front of a
microphone then they won't get money
from the nrcc or the d triple c to get
re-elected yeah and or what's nrcc
national republican congressional
commissioner
it's all about that party getting it i
told you man there's four people in that
building that have any power it's the
majority leader the minority leader on
one side and the speaker the minority
leader on the other what happens
like if you crowdfund everything so
you're and it's all about campaign
finance is supposed to be crowdfunding
except the donor lists are all kept and
held tight by the yeah all right let's
read this
uh axi says i said say axel two x's am i
the only one who thinks sheamus's
impression of jordan peterson sounds
like kermit the frog no i love the show
i came for tim but stayed free what's i
mean this is just how drunk peterson
sounds like i love jordan peterson but
like that's like yeah he has that it's
more like this a little and jordan
peterson's a bit higher he's more up
here the way he says his owes is like
all of just not doing it yeah and the
way like say psychologist psychologist
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it's like canadian kermit the frog
science exactly
justin force says the media cheered when
demonstrators risk derailing a train by
setting fire to the tracks but call it
fascism to use peaceful non-compliance
against the government
that should be the greatest wake-up call
take that cartoon showing working-class
people protesting which is their fascist
and share it with your friends and
family and then when you have a family
member who's like i don't believe this i
watch cnn be like do you think it's
fascist if working-class people are
fighting back against the elites and
like well no of course not here's the
here's the washington post saying stop
the people from resisting us you know
what's so evil
those fascist truckers we have political
cartoonists who want fascist truckers in
the workforce i thought the whole idea
is we wanted to push these people out of
the system get them canceled take their
jobs from them
and and they want those fascist truckers
back on the job insane they're not
anti-fascist enough not anti-fashion
shut up and get to work exactly they
they are protecting uh the jobs of
fascists so lydia you said you checked
my twitter and i and so i got like
called out by dinesh d'souza because i i
tweeted at one point like
anti-fascism is something i think we can
all get behind and denesha souza goes
now we've got conservative republicans
saying they're part of antifa and i'm
like no literally i think anti-fascism
is something we could all get behind yep
so ah yeah but they use clever word
games they do so that if you ever say
you're you know you oppose fascism then
you must be a communist oh you're not
pro-choice you mean you don't want to
allow anyone to choose to do their own
thing oh okay then yeah
what fandom says have you seen the
latest information on the shroud of
turin proven to be authentic i have not
seen that have you seen that the second
i haven't seen the latest information i
know it's something that's gone back and
forth i believe it's authentic but it's
really
apparently buried jesus in yeah they
recovered it at some point it's like
it's like an artifact
but they can't carbon date it because it
was in a fire or something i don't
remember all the details it's been a
while since i've looked at this there's
there's there's a lot it goes pretty
deep and it's been people have been very
back and forth on it all right let's
read this we got mr obvious says i don't
agree with immigration in a time where
there's not enough to go around for
americans america has starving children
and people living in poverty they are
hurt hardest by an influx of cheap labor
i just don't know how to stop it
uh one way
that they did historically and we're not
doing that at the very least they could
be like you've entered the country
illegally we will now send you back and
at the very most you look at what the
romans would do which is just take
families and tribes and cities worth of
people that were trying to migrate
across the river and kill them all so
like yeah no no no no we don't do that
no so how do you deal with well you
don't you don't put them on secret
charter flights we're not even trying to
however
how do you deal with it though i really
want to you put them on secret charter
flights back to the countries where they
originate from back to where they're
citizens
the wall i used to laugh at it i kind of
understand oh you see see this is the
funniest thing when trump was like i'm
going to build a big beautiful wall from
sea to shining sea 30 feet high or
whatever and then the wall just got 10
feet higher and all that stuff and the
left was like walls don't work and then
i think it was greece built a three
meter high fence and illegal immigration
dropped by 95 oh my goodness it was just
a chain-link fence they didn't even put
money into it so when everybody was
being driven out of the middle east by
isis turkey actually had a wall built
between themselves and the kurdish
populations in iraq syria and iran and
the eu paid for it and i'm like there it
is yeah well also how could you even say
something like that walls don't work
like obviously it's going to stop some
people this is a matter of probability
yeah but they'd like to show videos
where like someone's skinny and can slip
through the bothered fencing and or
where it's not complete people walk
through it and it's like
you this was really funny they'd be like
trump didn't complete any of the wall he
only built
the fencing where there were already
fences and though they don't show you
that the original fence is like a four
foot high log on a post and the new the
new wall is a three layer barrier and
what they don't tell you is that the
areas that trump reinforced were the hot
spots where all of the people were
constantly coming through so they
reinforced the most you know the worst
spots
okay
like the idea that walls don't work is
the stupidest thing we live in we live
in walls yeah an argument trumpeted by
people who live in gated communities
yeah exactly exactly that's right yeah
like people in yes people break in a
gated community sometimes no one is
claiming that a wall would stop 100 of
everybody but it would help yes
all right let's see we got here this is
uh murph says sheamus another way to
think of a nation taking care of their
own is a parent who will feed the other
kids in the neighborhood thinking it's
charitable but not feeding their own
children exactly this gets back to the
principle of subsidiary which is that
that which is most appropriate to use
that which is closest to you you have
certain responsibilities that you need
to fulfill before you go and try to take
care of everybody else so part of the
devolution away from a brilliant system
that we were bequeathed by our founders
is
not
prioritizing those things for which
government is actually responsible right
so when i was doing state work i would
ask myself first is this appropriate for
government but the most important
question is at this level because the
county doesn't need an army but the
federal government should probably have
one right so yeah we've just lost it
we've completely lost it no politician
wants to vote against anything that's a
good idea because it could hurt them at
the
instead of saying to the body politic to
the electorate hey look guys this might
be a good idea it's not our job right
like if you want and i live in a rural
area if you want the government to if
you want good high-speed internet
don't let the federal government pay for
it right
think about when you try to call the irs
but your county government might have an
appropriate role in that right so
all right
atherin says i want to recommend quote
the science of storytelling by will
store in it he explains the neuroscience
of storytelling tom said these guys
ain't lying they've drunk the kool-aid
this book explains how and why
very interesting
sniper says ever since i heard about the
uyghur muslims and what china was doing
to them i'll never forget it and i'll
never
i'll never ever stop thinking about it
yeah it's crazy man the following gong
is crazy too
and the crazy propaganda they try to run
here in the u.s i i get comments still i
don't know if i'm going to i probably
will whenever i talk about the chinese
government the ccp i get people on
twitter usually are like you you've
fallen for the propaganda the ccp is
totally benevolent there's no evidence
and like i don't know who to believe
what i love is virginia we have free
tibet license plates always on cars
belonging to people who would never do
anything to sanction the chinese who
suppressed and subjugated tibet the
tibet those are the falun gong in sabat
no no the falun gong is
more to the
east but tibet's a nation state that's
been essentially subsumed by china so
i'm going to free tibet but i'm not
willing to lift the finger to do it and
again we're not talking about troops on
the ground we're talking about standing
up and saying you guys that's not right
all right marco says hey tim i heard you
were interested in having
representatives from west virginia on
how would someone go about scheduling
with you guys to get on
uh i don't know
i don't know we can we can we can look
at look
we'll have to look at the west virginia
reps yeah and then reach out to them i
suppose it's the problem with
politicians sorry politicians is that
we'll reach out and be like hey we'd
love to have you on the show you know
this thing happened and they'll say oh
man we'd love to come on send an email
to this person we go you got it and then
we do and they never respond why is it
somebody somewhere who is not elected by
anyone has read something on the
internet where they deem that there's a
greater risk than reward from having
been on your show politics this is why
for the most part i i'm just not
interested in asking politicians to come
on
only only some and a few
like uh we've reached out to to some and
they've agreed to and i will say this
you know uh we're planning on having dan
crench on the show we reached out to him
and he was like we'll find a time and
then he was like yeah i can make it i
can make it work and
respect him for doing it a lot of people
are mad at him for a lot of you know
different things that happened in the
press but he's willing to come on the
show and talk about whatever and
whatever so i'm i'm i'm
awesome glad glad it's gonna happen from
your perspective tom having been a
politician do you think that there's
value to doing shows like this as a
policy so
my fear with exiled series.com is that
we'll get like cubbyholed as a
right-wing thing or a christian thing or
whatever thing this is a human freedom
thing um
but i tell you like if there is a
podcast that is the opposite of tim cast
i'll go on but because this is a story
that like we should be to freaking
believe in right but yeah look the issue
right now is you know obviously
everybody knows if you ask me i'm just
like civil war and whatever form that
may take it's not going to look like it
was in the 1800s but we're here when joe
rogan who believes in universal basic
income
who supported you know bernie sanders
had him on his show
and often touts you know relatively like
left social policy and left economic
policy is called far-right dangerous
misinformation over like one guest right
there's look they're they're they're
claiming he's all right far right and
all that stuff and and joe's almost a
socialist
so it doesn't even matter what the show
is it breaks down to this if the show
tells the truth
it's going to be called right wing if
the show lies
it's probably establishment corporate or
democratic and in mao's china they would
be considered left-wing they were all
leftists they or no they were right as
rightists they would condemn the
rightists so stand by for the canceling
of bill maher in like three two one
right i mean as soon as you start
getting out of the orthodoxy then maybe
or bill maher is a fair weather liberal
who waited until it was safe enough and
now he's coming out and criticizing all
the stuff two years later because we
might be seeing the end of the pandemic
so he may just be another corporate show
i just i
again though i mean
we talked about the vaccine right donald
trump rams through a vaccine and 1 14th
of the time that his historical
scientific protocol dictates why why do
we have these review periods two reasons
primarily number one to make sure
there's efficacy and number two that the
harm doesn't outweigh the benefit we
throw those rules out the window the
same group of people who said everything
this guy does is evil
are like you gotta go get the vaccine
and i'm like there's no consistency
anywhere well yeah yeah so in in 2020
you have all these people saying they
would never get it now these are the
people saying you better go get it or
else politically
it's all right it's all tribal it's all
it's all tribal you know and and because
of this
it's difficult to have certain
conversations on youtube because youtube
is clearly within one tribe but you know
what i think we're winning but i'm not
advocating for a decision either way i'm
advocating for a thorough review of the
facts right i said earlier like the last
radio show i did the the was a
philosophical argument and the question
was if you can choose between truth and
freedom which you choose my answer is
choose truth it will beget freedom we're
losing truth therefore it is reasonable
to presume that if we lose it we'll lose
freedom all right let's read some more
we got dw he says youtuber crs firearms
was arrested yesterday by the atf for
made-up bogus charges please but please
let people know to look him up and
support him well i don't know much about
it but you know y'all can look it up and
see what's going on there
all right brian says there has to be a
federal law that prohibits media
companies from being traded on the stock
market taking the corporate out of
corporate media
perhaps perhaps
i don't know if that that i think that
creates as many problems horrible
cause of course npr is completely
reliable they're not publicly traded
right
and google's alphabet's not a media
corporation
all right burrito boy says the canadian
government's propaganda wing has labeled
the freedom convoy a white supremacist
movement makes you wonder about agent
provocateurs also first ever super chat
love the show keep it up hey you
appreciate it
hot dog says do anthony fauci singing
tragedy from the bee gees
which song is that that's i don't know
but i think fauci would sing staying
alive about the vaccine
that's a good one
i'm staying alive wearing hell masks by
the way
i use my walk i'm a woman's man no time
to talk
because the droplets will come out at
all land on your grandmother
i i i was listening to fauci and rand
paul and i was like my voice doesn't
really sound like crazy no that sounds
pretty good i thought you're gonna say i
was listening to the bg's for a second
well it's like i do a very gruff version
yeah it works dude also people can't
tell it's your voice so i know that's
really funny yeah so i i voice you on
his his cartoon
and people are like no way that's tim
yeah it was cool i was listening to it
but i was i had forgotten it was you and
then but i was listening to it it was
like that's awesome i was like oh yeah i
love that when you forget like
alex jones into me oh my gosh yeah yeah
don't don't no don't say anymore you and
you and i are gonna just don't wanna
anymore yeah yeah yeah all right lane
says ian is like a dnd character who
rolls either a one or twenty for
perception checks on conversations i
always love the oh is there more yeah
wouldn't it be the same without him ps
love you sheamus have been a fan of you
longer than i have tim hot topic i love
you thank you i i i just want to say
real quick ian this is correct you
either roll a one or two but it's not
but it's not by design wait it is by
design that's what i meant um no i like
the charac playing the fallout run
through every once in a while if you
guys probably play follow with a really
stupid character because they have a
whole new form of of of dialogue choices
when they're really stupid it's funny i
think that's funny too but so do you
understand dan dietl
so i just know that there's been a test
admission that ian owns 20-sided dice so
there's no doubt it basically means that
perception
if ian rolls a 20 he's gonna articulate
this amazing thought that invigorates
the conversation when he rolls a one he
sounds like a [ __ ] i think it's because
if i start and it's not working i just
kind of give up and it fizzles into
weirdness i try to keep going but we're
on a tv we're totally a certain amount
of time
all right let's grab some more super
chats
all right there's a elwood blues alex e
jones for president is is that alex's
middle name is or whatever yes alex oh
yeah eugene i don't know has tim ever
explored brock's candy in chicago before
it was demoed i didn't know it was and
no i didn't emerick
all right
yeah pit zoo says switzerland is neutral
and they have border walls
yes switzerland's where the bank of
international settlements is
headquarters the neutrality is nice when
you run the economy i just don't 20 or a
1. it's
that's a 20. i think i wrote a set i
think i wrote a 17 on that i don't know
if i beat the armored class i think
what's so insane about that though the
mentioning that switzerland is neutral i
mean it's a point you have to make
nowadays but the idea that having a
border is a political statement is so
ridiculous
i mean if we follow down that track for
50 years it's a one world utopia where
everyone holds hands under the rainbow
and all that stuff right right is that
what they're claiming yeah yeah all
right john stalling says i'm from
missouri and i'd love to see you reach
out to josh hawley is that in the works
that'd be so cool yeah i'd love to have
josh hawley on the show but look it is
so insanely difficult to get politicians
they're so busy too they're busy and
often they're not in dc we're really
close to dc we're an hour from dc so you
know even that's too hard for a lot of
these people yeah it's going to be a lot
harder now that i'm playing every now
and again you know yeah plus time made a
really good point they're going to be
like oh we got invited on this big
podcast yeah
no it's somebody's somebody who who
didn't get elected who shouldn't have
the authority will go you don't want to
do it here's why and they're going to be
too busy to do their own homework you
know who i want to have on the show
who's that lady running for governor in
in uh florida you know what i'm talking
about uh is it um nikki freed or
something is it oh nikki freed internet
breed i'd love to have her on the show
that'd be so fun yeah she's running
against desantis in florida
and i she posted something i thought was
really interesting and i was like i
would love to discuss these ideas
uh it was not not that she was wrong
about something it was like
she said something about restoring
freedom but being opposed to gun rights
and then i was like i would love to have
a philosophical discussion about what
that means
you know what does that look like like
only the state should be able to use
violence against people but we want you
to be free
something like that can't protect
yourself and your family i think
republicans should right now
abolish the atf yes repeal the nfa yes
and uh
should there be a convention of states
we should uh we should have an amendment
which is just called the second
amendment
a
where it's like it's basically the exact
same language as the second amendment
but we just want to make sure everyone's
clear on this
this time around we just write shall not
be influenced
right right
again for those in the back we actually
meant this yes
all right
oh hot
i don't know how to pronounce it
whatever it says uh ohadocaro
oha tarkail
okay i know this is kind of a broken
record but why haven't you had the adv
china guys on a lot of the stuff you
talk about on china lines up with them i
don't know why i'm waiting yeah why
haven't we that's why
yeah and laughs
yeah
yeah that'd be cool yeah
all right
nicholas cronkite says hello tim and
friends i'm putting my name in
for
uh nevada governor i'm going to run on
no more mandates a return to normal and
making nevada a two-way sanctuary state
the governor's job is to protect your
rights not take them fro not take them
from you best of luck good sir sounds
sounds good
all right
roadrunner says ian means well but he
must be careful
uh his want to not step on others
doesn't cause evil sometimes the right
thing is not the kindest
yeah
that's a pro mean tweets comment that
you got yeah hunter says michael savage
defined a nation as borders language
culture it's a good way to look at it in
my opinion yeah i think the problem in
the united states is that we have no
community anymore
people don't view each other in this
country as neighbors they view each
other not as neighbors so even though we
have a greater umbrella constitution in
government
people in certain neighborhoods don't
view their other neighborhood neighbors
as friends people don't view other
politics as americans a judge in
pennsylvania says you're a republican so
we rule against you and it's just i've
been finding since internet video age
that i have more in common sometimes
with like an australian guy that i meet
and i'm like well you're just a smart
per like i just get your i understand
you rather than just because i i was
born next door to that guy who i went to
high school and school with kids that i
don't even ever see anymore they're like
i don't stay in touch with them just
because i was from there
you know so it's out of this global
homogeneity borders culture and language
well culture is dispersed throughout the
globe now language almost everybody
speaks english so
other than the borders what's keeping
this
unifying this country and what are the
borders even so when i was reading
when i was reading up on on you i heard
you like kpop
no okay well who said that you might
have heard that
is that real did someone say like that
truly i was like just doing that deep
dive on like his temple i honestly don't
know anything about k-pop i know but the
point that's not true
yeah right that's that's what i know the
point that i'm making is that there that
there there is still definitive culture
right and and i've been again really
blessed to spend time in a lot of places
i've got more common with somebody in
south central los angeles than i do with
somebody
uh
in in uh mongolia it ain't even close
you know what let me let me read this
one more super chat noah zork says
answer your own question expose
politicians that won't talk in public by
inviting them promote the ones that will
why don't we do that
put all politicians on notice and this
may mean that no politician ever wants
to come on again
if we reach out to a politician and they
don't respond we'll just tell everyone
we reached out to this politician to
come on the show they didn't respond if
they do and then they don't show up
we'll say that and if they do and they
do show up well you'll see them on the
show that's right and then we can start
being like
you know i'll say it like this we
reached out to politicians so and so
they're under no obligation to give us
their time they're very busy but they
did not respond to a request to have him
on the show simple as that i'm not
trying to dictate that people you know
that we're owed anything like that but
there's a lot of people we've invited on
the show and i'm sure people would want
to know who we did invite yeah and and
you know why why uh
they didn't respond or didn't end up
coming on and i think that's you know
that's fair these are politicians these
are not you know private people these
are public officials yeah so with that
being said smash that like button right
now subscribe to this channel share the
show if you really do like it tell your
friends about it and become a member at
timcast.com if you want to support the
work we do because
membership is our principal funding it's
how we we have everybody working here
it's how we we grow
it's the principle way we do it because
we do have sponsors obviously but uh
it's with your support that we're able
to expand so again timkes.com you can
follow the show at timcast irl on
instagram you can follow me at timcast
basically everywhere also on instagram
tom you want to shout anything out yeah
man so everything tim said better than i
can exile series.com go take a look at
the trailer um i believe in it i hope
you will but by gosh if we get eyes on
this product we're going to fund this
product so social media share it get it
out there there are people who are far
less fortunate than you if you know if
you can't give a buck then then then
give a share
and uh thanks so much for the
opportunity guys what an honor
all 20s by the way yeah yeah critical
success
um
yeah thank you so much for having me on
tonight tim it's uh always a privilege
to be able to be uh second chair while
i'm filling in for he who has dearly
missed he's just assuming that ian's
third champion's third chair now
now um i'm seamus coughlin check me out
freedom tunes
t-o-o-n-s this is my youtube channel i
do political cartoons and i think you
guys would probably enjoy them we
released one yesterday about the masks
that i was i was pretty happy with and
we release every thursday sometimes on
tuesdays as well what's the other
channel
the fee channel oh yeah so i also run a
channel with the foundation for economic
education called common sense soapbox
but common sense so so if comments and
soapbox i have a couple other things
that i handle they're all linked to on
the freedom tunes channel so if you go
over there you'll be able to see all of
it sweet cool you can follow me at ian
crossland.net tom you're also garrett
and exile on twitter i don't know if you
could i was going i was literally
looking to see who i yeah in exile and
twitter and it's new but yeah do follow
again thank you so much thank you for
making this and pouring yourself into
this how long have you been doing this
how long have you been oh gosh so this
is like we're supposed to be done right
i want to be respectful of you um this
thing started before we knew it started
it started when we went into sedan and
got those guys out and um and then uh
just kept like so i recovering alcohol
three years eight months and five days
and i'm like what do i want to do with
my life this [ __ ] feels right because
this stuff is stuff that matters helping
people who can't help themselves
and compelled charities not charity
yeah but but every every single life has
value we should be doing something about
it this is exile series dot com exile
series dot com thanks man god bless you
guys thanks
yeah i'm really excited to hear about
this series and i hope this documentary
really takes off i hope all of you guys
will go over and check out
exilesseries.com and see what tom has
been up to very hard work very
interesting neat challenging stuff you
guys may follow me on twitter at sarah
patchoulits and also on mines make sure
to check out the cast castle vlog over
at
youtube.comcastcastle because we have a
video up every single day and you can
watch the shenanigans that happens here
in the castle and just keep in mind it's
a semi-fictitious you know show where we
make you know jokes and gags and sheamus
tortures people so what thanks for
hanging out everybody i'm all there just
asking questions
you